Hello!
Let's play some jazz.
Hello, hello everyone!
Hello!
The final heist!
The last stream!
I didn't want to swap scenes.
I just wanted to stay there forever.
So it will be a never ending starting stream.
If we never start the stream, we never end.
Think about that!
I was like, maybe let's wait a bit longer.
Let's wait a bit longer.
Oh guys, there's so many of you.
Thank you so much for the raid!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you Hana!
And also the raids.
Oh my gosh, there's so many raids.
Natsuki!
Thank you!
Oh, I was going to say thank you Acer for the raid, but that was a prime sub.
Thank you Acer for the Twitch Prime for 13 13 months.
And Raru for the raid.
And Crunchy for also a sub for 8 months at tier 1.
Thank you!
Thank you everyone!
Let's get some Bark Knights real quick for the three.
Let's get some last final claps and Bark Knights guys.
And Sontier for the 23 months in tier 1.
Some last final Bark Knights everyone.
For all the new subbers and the resubbers.
This is the final heist.
The final one guys.
Thank you everyone.
Thank you, thank you!
I really do appreciate it guys.
Thank you so much.
Oh gosh, I am actually have never I have never been like Thank you for the raid too.
I have never been so stressed out for a stream.
Because it's like I can't believe.
I never thought I would I would like stop a stream.
You know like stop streaming.
I never thought this would ever happen.
It's just crazy.
I am going to wake up the next week while I am on the run at a Motel 6 with my bunnies and be like I don't have to stream.
.
Thank you everyone.
Oswald!
Thank you for the 10 gifted subs!
Thank you, thank you!
Can we get some more?
Can we get some more Barkknights real quick?
For Oswald.
For giving 10 subs to the community.
Thank you so much Oswald.
Thank you, thank you.
It really does mean so much.
And Kitsune for the 36 months of tier 1.
Thank you guys.
I really do appreciate it everyone.
Thank you for all the subs.
The alerts are not on right now because I will be putting this VOD...
Oh I am just going to clap all day.
Thank you everyone.
Thank you.
I don't have the alerts sound on just because I am going to be putting this stream up onto YouTube as an archive for all of you.
So I don't think it would be great to have like the screaming Yoshi in the background for 20 minutes straight while I am watching.
I am trying to talk.
It would be like, by the way...
Bop, bop, bop.
Thank you Kitsune.
Thank you for the 1000 vids in fame for the 4 months.
More claps, more claps.
I just can't stop clapping.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh shit, sorry.
One of my bunnies like dropped something.
And Momo, thank you for the giving of subs to Ogle.
Thank you.
More bark nights guys.
More bark nights.
And Arlo for the 10.
Everyone this is the final stream.
The final time to cash in on those bark nights.
Thank you everyone.
Thank you.
And Hannah for the 100 bids.
Thank you everyone.
Thank you MoFo for not giving the subs to Mufi.
Oh my bark nights guys.
Thank you everyone.
So my plan for today.
I don't want to like drag on the stream for really long because I want to make it nice and sweet for all of you.
So we are not going to be playing like 20 different games and having like a 20 hour stream.
So the current set list for the stream is we are going to do the tour.
The final tour of the community Minecraft server.
Um, maybe a little small karaoke request.
Song request.
Of songs I have sung before.
Cause I, okay to be I really wanted to prep prep for a karaoke set list for all of you.
But I was, my last final weeks were so packed with so many things to prepare and everything that I couldn't, I couldn't like learn new songs for you guys.
I'm so sorry.
It was like, I didn't expect us to hit so many charity goals.
Too.
So also Juki thank you for the 30 bits.
Thank you.
Like I didn't expect to hit so many uh, uh charity goals.
So I had to like, I stuffed my remaining weeks to to like prep for the streams for those.
So, so we are just going to we can do a little set list of stuff.
I can sing to some little karaoke requests.
The songs I've sung before.
You guys just requested and I'll look through it.
But oh my gosh, thank you everyone.
Thank you.
Screamy Yoshi is kind of a classic though.
Yeah, but I feel like it's going to be there for a while.
I feel like the Screaming Yoshi's will be there for a long time.
Hahaha Yeah, Miss She and FlyCham thank you for the five tier one community sub gives.
And FlyCham for the for the tier one.
More claps.
More, more bark nights guys.
More bark nights for everyone.
For the new bark nights.
And Crouchy for the fifty.
Thank you.
Thank you everyone.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I really do.
I really will miss you guys.
I really will.
I remember I saw a comment.
What will you be doing if I'm not streaming?
Well, I'll be on the run.
Like I have to constantly move around or I'm going to get caught by the authorities.
Hahaha Also, also thank you for the three.
Fifty.
Fifty dollars.
Fifty dollars too.
Thank you everyone.
Oh gosh.
It did go by so fast this month.
I honestly thought four weeks was gonna was not gonna like was gonna take a while.
But I it felt so fast.
It felt like every stream was just like an eye blink away.
It's crazy.
I never expected it to go by this fast.
There's lots of tonight.
Lots of tonight for the final heist is me.
Uh yoinking the subs and the money.
Hahaha No I didn't.
I really didn't anticipate this at all.
I really didn't think you guys.
Hahaha I really thank you everyone.
I can't even say that with a straight face cause I honestly I honestly didn't expect this at all.
Cause I was like this is gonna be the final stream.
You guys don't have to give me anything any anymore guys.
You really don't.
Hahaha People making you all this stuff.
Who's gonna pay for the motel sticks huh?
Look at who's money is aren't.
Hahaha Um Were the results of sending the... Oh I posted it on Twitter.
That was an... That was an Insta reject.
Hahaha They're like... No not instant.
It took them like three days of like looking through my application.
It was like is she serious?
And then I got the rejection.
Every other ones I submitted took like one to two days.
This one took me like took me like three days.
So they were actually a bit confused.
They were they were... Hahaha Hahaha.
Also thank you to whoever is the non-skipter for giving us stuff to out of you.
Thank you thank you.
Go get some more park nights and chat for whoever the non-skipter is.
Thank you everyone.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
I really... Thank you.
It really does.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you everyone.
Hahaha It was three days already.
The script was too long.
Hahaha They were concerned.
They were like hmm Yamashiii.
Thank you for the fifty dollars.
That's five nights at the motel six I booked tomorrow.
That's why I have more nights there.
Hahaha Hahaha.
And do go for the three months in a row.
Thank you.
I love you guys too.
I really do guys.
I really...
And ah thank you everyone.
More park nights.
I hope this chat is spam with park nights.
Thank you everyone.
The final stream with all these park nights and everyone.
Guys thank you.
Hahaha.
Thirty nine subs.
Holy shit.
Hahaha.
Everyone it really does mean so much.
Thank you.
I can't really say how... like say that enough guys.
I really can't.
You can't talk about motels.
I'm not keeping it secret.
Hahaha.
Alright guys.
So.
First off we're gonna do a little Minecraft tour.
Um of the Minecraft community tour.
So we still be active on the discord.
I will not be.
I will be leaving the discord.
I've decided that after much consideration I will be leaving the server.
And we'll be handing it over to someone.
Who will be... who will... the discord now is all closed.
So no one can get in anymore.
Um but it will... ah it will live on from you guys.
My park nights will live on in the server.
But I will be leaving it.
Handing the control over to um someone I trust.
So you'll find out at the end of this stream more details about it.
Yeah no way in and no way out.
You ain't leaving.
You're not going anywhere.
Hahaha.
How dare you wanna leave the server.
The doors are all gone.
I deleted the door.
Hahaha.
This is... the server was my sim game all along.
I actually only used their doki recently.
Thanks to Nex.
But I promise I'll be here for the finals.
Ah thank you.
Time.
Thank you.
She went and took the ladder out of the pool.
You may not enter or leave.
Welcome to tomato limbo.
Hahaha.
Her rashes are already really thick.
It's time to eat the other tomato children guys.
Why do you think I grew all these tomatoes for?
Hahaha.
Alright guys.
I'm gonna set up for the server now.
For those of you who don't know the community server.
It was a at first it was a single player server.
And where I was trying to build a hallway.
And then for the final two weeks you guys all wanted me to open it up to everyone.
So I decided to so we did a community server and I'm going to be touring around all your creations.
And then I made you guys.
It was like free labor to finish my hallway too.
So it was like a win-win for everyone.
You get to walk the hallway.
And free labor.
Hahaha.
Isn't that great?
I had a great time.
So yeah the last two days I couldn't work on it anymore.
So I made I made everyone else work on it.
Hahaha.
I heard a few people have died on the sky hallway.
Cause I made the hallway in the sky.
And then people fell off of it.
Cause I didn't finish the sky hallway.
And I'm sorry.
Hahaha.
Not really though.
I mean...
Hahaha.
Alright let me.
I'll put the back screen real quick so I can set up the uh set up the the server screen.
Alright I'll be right back guys.
I'll be right back.
Hello?
Alright.
Where's Minecraft?
Where did you go Minecraft?
Hahaha.
Where did you go?
But I saw a question about what will happen to the YouTube videos.
It will remain Oh there we go.
It will remain forever on YouTube.
So don't worry about the graduation uh because I will upload the graduation vod onto YouTube.
And also so those.
Oh it's night time.
Oh that's bad.
Alright so this is actually uh not where we're supposed to go first.
But um um also uh oh my donation thing isn't updating.
Oh thanks for the like.
Thanks for letting me know.
I'll put that.
I just realized I forgot to open up stream labels.
Haha.
Hahaha.
I was like I won't be scum.
I triple quadruple checked everything.
Whoop.
Nevermind.
Hahaha.
And the person who did the beard back animation is Mithlu.
Mithlu did that for me.
Alright so let me show you.
This is where you spawn in.
So uh this was what I like to call the peepee beacon.
You climb up the big peepee.
And hahaha.
You're like where are where am I?
Where did I did this by the way.
Where do I go?
So um we climb we climb this long tower up here.
And then you're like oh that's where we go.
See oh and this is like a giant tomato.
Oh so shit the daily song.
Ah let's listen to the daily song multiple times while we explore.
In true Doki Doki Maple Bird fashion we shall listen to the daily song on repeat because I know a lot of you have redeemed it.
Wait what?
Hahaha.
What is this?
Allow ads on.
Yes please.
Hahaha.
This is not this isn't the daily song.
Wait why is it not giving me the daily song.
Hahaha.
Ah scuff to the end.
Truly beautiful.
You know what there we go.
There we go.
Hahaha.
Betrayed.
Alright.
Yeah I got the pack easy.
I got the pack.
Alright.
I got so many people killed on the the pee pee beacon.
So it's basically you're like where do I go?
And then oh that's my shovel.
Hahaha.
Okay and then you uh you jump here.
And go.
Ah that's where I go.
And then let me dig.
Wow that's a skeleton.
Hahaha.
Let me let me head home first guys.
So.
Popular candy.
Ashima threw out some scuff.
True exactly.
Scyany.
I'm the devil of the ball.
The star of the show.
Yeah.
Type of pony.
Please.
Skeleton please.
This is my final.
Oh I almost.
This is my final stream.
Hahaha.
Streamer.
Alright so.
What's gonna happen.
The Minecraft server will survive for a month.
And then whatever happens to it.
And then what happens to it is Azer's decision.
Alright so this is Azer's house right?
So I uh don't tell Azer cause he can't watch the stream and listen and watch the stream and listen and play Minecraft at the same time.
But I killed one of his bees by accident.
I took this flint out and I was like oh what's this?
And then I right clicked into the.
I right clicked into it.
Hahaha.
Don't tell Azer.
He doesn't know.
Hahaha.
No he doesn't.
He doesn't know.
Hahaha.
Also what's this?
This is up.
And this is someone's home.
I don't know whose home this is.
Oh my god.
I almost.
I should not have this out.
I almost lit his home on fire.
I'm sorry.
I almost lit it on fire.
Alright so.
Uh what's this?
What's this?
Where is it?
Oh it's here.
It's Ito-san.
What does Ito-san do?
Oh he restores.
Are you still burning my house?
I'm so sorry.
Thank you so much for the 5000 bits.
Thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Alright so this is the tomato.
Uh the tomato god.
Which is me.
Hahaha.
That's me.
And that's also me.
Look at me with my children.
Before I eat them.
This is also me.
Hahaha.
This is my home.
Let me introduce you to my home.
So this is the...
Changes were made.
Um because my...
Wait where do I go?
Oh.
Hahaha.
Changes were made.
And I wasn't aware of these changes.
Some of these changes.
So people were getting tired of opening every door.
From my Minecraft house.
So.
Wait is this the hallway?
Oh my god.
Hahaha.
This is not.
Wait.
Wait this is not my house.
This is the hallway.
Anyway that's the hallway.
Hahaha.
I realized that that might not be my house.
That might not be my house.
I was like that's way too many doors.
That's way too many.
Too many doors to the hallway.
Anyway that's the end.
The hallway is the...
Wait is this my house?
No.
Wait is this my...
Anyway this is my house.
This is... oh let's... uh...
Hallway is as may as well be your house.
Hahaha.
Anyway this is my house.
Your slime is my favorite.
Hahaha.
Oh no they're my bark knights.
And look.
Oh!
I didn't know this was here.
Look at that.
I sleep and watch myself while I sleep.
Truly I am beautiful.
Hahaha.
I like to watch myself while I sleep.
So I would be the last thing I see before I close my eyes.
And then there's my...
There's the little bark knights.
You guys are here with us too.
So and then this is my mind shaft as well.
So there's like apparently chickens.
There's apparently chickens.
Someone decided to...
Uh...
Breed some chickens in my mind shaft.
So...
I don't know where they are.
This is the last time.
The cave chickens.
Yes the cave chickens.
I don't know where they are right now.
But they're in here somewhere.
Um you're hearing them go...
There he goes.
They're mine.
They're cave chickens.
There's like little cave chickens there.
So this is my mind shaft.
And um...
I'm just slowly going towards...
We're almost there.
Don't worry.
Don't worry guys.
We're almost... Don't worry guys.
We are here.
Look at that.
And then...
We're in the body shaft.
It's protection.
And then...
You can go this way.
Or this way.
Which is a cave.
We can try and find the chickens.
But we'll definitely won't be able to...
Uh...
We'll definitely won't be able to find our way out.
Hahahaha.
No it's extra protection every time.
Okay if you ever watch any zombie movie.
Or any like movie where there's monsters.
The reason why they die is that they don't close the door.
So this is extra protection.
You're welcome.
These doors have saved me so many times.
From monsters trying to get in.
There's no way in and no way out.
Just like the mystery.
Anyway let's...
Pony...
I mean pony...
Pony should know...
Also can one of the mon...
That's not supposed to be.
Can one of the mon...
Uh...
Link the daily song.
So how many doors...
Many trees have died for this.
Many many trees have died for this.
I'll be the toast of the town.
Extra protection for the mon...
Pony every pony every pony should know.
There we go.
And we're home.
Um...
We're home.
Look at that.
So these didn't exist before.
So people would just...
Open and close it.
I would just open and close it myself every time.
And then everyone got fed up with that.
Especially with the hallway.
So they built...
They built little like...
Those little like...
Thingies.
Alright whose house are we going next?
Who wants to leave me?
Oh there's B-man.
That was my house by the way guys.
And there's a little koi fish in here too.
There's a little koi fish in here.
Oh and my pool.
Let me show you my...
Diving pool.
Wait wait before...
Before we do that let me show you my...
Diving board.
So this is my first...
This is my first...
PP beacon.
Cause I... This was not my first house guys.
This was not my first house.
I had another house.
And then I got lost.
And I died.
So I started making...
The beacons to help me.
They were the first hallway.
I would like to call this...
The vertical hallway.
Also thank you Ed for the...
8 months at tier 3.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I'll do a little...
I'll do claps.
And then there's my flower.
I put this here.
But let's give a little...
Let's give a little clap.
Let's embark nice real quick...
For Ed for the 8 months at tier 3.
Thank you so much.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you.
It really means a lot.
Thank you so much.
And then... Alright.
Sparkies.
I owe you Twitch chat more than a million dollars.
Alright.
Let's go in.
Okay.
I need a...
That was...
I actually didn't want to die there.
And then...
Where do I go?
Who's leading me?
Who's gonna lead me?
So...
I'm gonna die twice.
Wait.
There's a horse.
Was it my horse?
Okay.
That's Doki.
That's Doki horse.
He jumped in there himself.
Cause he has a little... He really likes cows.
That's the Doki horse.
I couldn't find a dog.
So a horse was just...
A horse is like a bigger dog.
That you can ride.
Who's this?
Whose house is this?
Is this your house?
Rancid?
Alright.
This is Rancid's house.
I lied.
It's not that cool.
Yes.
Oh!
A little bunk.
What the fuck?
Okay.
I thought that was a little bunk bed.
For himself.
A Rancid hole.
Alright.
What's in here?
Is this a mineshaft?
Alright.
I'm just fucking leaving the mineshaft.
And there's Rancid's farm.
That's my tomato... potato now.
So that was Rancid's farm.
Rancid's house.
Was there more?
Rancid?
That was just scary.
I wish I made it...
Horses are just making dogs.
What happened to the trees?
Gone are distant doors.
Alright.
Let's do...
I think I have like two more plays of this.
Alright.
Whose house am I going next guys?
Who's leading?
Did I?
Did I hit him?
I'm sorry.
Who's leading me?
Who's gonna lead me?
I am a sheep.
I don't know where to go.
I never looked into...
I don't know where...
Where you guys built your stuff.
How am I supposed to know where to go?
You can see the villager gulag.
The villager gulag?
Alright.
And there's me.
And this guy.
Whose house is that?
Let's go to that house.
Am I not running?
How do I run?
Wait.
Do I have auto sprint off?
Where's auto sprint?
Where is it?
Is there auto sprint?
I don't know how to play this game.
Please.
How do I run?
Am I running?
I'm running right?
Hahaha.
I don't even know if I'm running.
Everything feels so slow.
Hahaha.
Alright.
You know what?
This is grandma.
Here's mine too.
That's mine now.
Whose house is this?
Hahaha.
I can't even take it.
I'm too high.
I stole too many things guys.
I stole too many things.
Hahaha.
Oh.
And there's a house over here.
So you have to hold your sprint key every time you want to sprint.
Oh that's dumb.
Also, BOMBTASTIC!
Thank you for the 8 months on tier 1.
Let's do a little class.
Can we get some bark knights real quick for BOMBTASTIC for the 8 months at tier 1.
Thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Thank you BOMBTASTIC.
This is the final sub.
Truly it is.
I'm the type of pony.
Everypony.
Whose house is this?
Oh.
Oh what the fuck?
Alright.
And thus I steal another.
I steal one thing from everyone.
I almost like ran over.
Well I was gonna say I almost ran over.
Ran over his cross but I don't really know how to run.
Apparently.
I don't know.
Hahaha.
Just collecting my taxes.
Just collecting my taxes real quick.
Oh is that the dog house?
Alright.
Let's check the dog house.
Ninja's dog house.
Oh!
It's DonkeyDodge!
Oh my god!
Hahaha.
I didn't expect to see that.
Oh.
It's okay.
I have Eta's sword.
Wait.
I can't see my HP.
I can't see my HP!
Hahaha.
Wait.
It ran past?
Oh!
It's a red one!
Oh that's... Charlie thank you for three months of time!
Thank you!
What is that?
Oh my god.
Is this a shrine?
For my dog?
Hahaha.
Oh my god!
All hell DonkeyDodge!
All hell.
Hahaha.
Look.
Look, dookie.
Look, DonkeyDodge.
I robbed some wheat for you.
All hell, DonkeyDodge!
Operating chamber!
What is this?
Left fire costume.
Oh that is it!
Hahaha.
Woo!
What the fuck?
Hahaha.
I got burned.
Woo!
I ran into it!
Dog is love.
Dog is life.
Alright, so that was...
Hahaha.
What are these then?
Oh is that just...
Time to work.
My taxes.
Gotta take your taxes.
Gotta collect your taxes.
Oh there's a naked sheep.
What a fascinating...
religion.
Hahaha.
That was a dokey doke shrine.
I did not... I was not ready for that.
I was not ready for that.
I ran out of...
I ran out of tea guys.
Someone...
Someone give me more.
Hahaha.
Someone feed me.
Alright, what's next?
Who wants to lead me to the... What?
Get back here?
Is there more?
There's more.
Oh the DJ...
The DJ bedroom.
Hahaha.
Beautiful.
It's truly... truly...
Oh it's the... it's the...
It's me licking Sonic toes.
You guys do not know what this emote is.
We were watching Sonic the Hedgehog.
And like the guy rendered Sonic toes very very well.
And then I drew this emote for my community.
Hahaha.
It is beautiful.
Oh I can't sleep.
It's not day time.
Hahaha.
I drew that while we were watching the movie together.
We had like a movie night where we were watching Sonic.
The new Sonic movie.
And that... whoever animated Sonic's toes.
I wanna know how many hours they spent on it.
Cause it was way too detailed.
It was way too...
Way too...
Wait it's like those like...
What was it?
iCarly?
The iCarly show where the creative iCarly really really likes toes.
So people really like to take off their socks in that show.
I...
Hahaha.
I don't know if you guys really noticed that.
But there's a lot of shots of that there.
Isn't that a great final stream?
Me talking about...
So... this is my hallway guys.
Don't worry.
We will... Should we go through the hallway?
Are there any?
Oh let's just go through the hallway.
You know what?
We should... Wait wait no no.
We should look at the mountain.
The mountain.
So I would like to show you the mountain that sacrificed its life.
To... to...
Uh... to make the hallway.
So I did this.
I...
Hahaha.
This was half of...
This was a... This used to be a full mountain guys.
I made it.
Hahaha.
The mountain gave it half its life for us.
So...
Also like I got very... I got very like stingy about it.
I actually like flattened it myself.
I was like mmm... And I cooked... I cooked cobblestone.
Uh...
To make stone.
So I could repair...
I could repair the mountain.
Hahaha.
Whoa!
Don't cut it!
Hahaha.
Okay.
One of us is in sleep.
So... I cropped it.
I cropped the... I cropped the... Protect the bear!
Protect me!
You guys are fucking terrible at protecting.
Hahaha.
So yeah I did that.
I did that.
Anyway let's play some... You know what?
Let's play some...
Oh shit.
What's a good song?
Oh!
Okay.
Alright.
Let's do some...
Um...
Let's make... Let's put some songs in there real quick while we...
Look five mic.
Hahaha.
Alright.
So let's start the mountain now.
We shall start the hallway.
Yeah I'll do the hallway last.
I'll do the hallway last.
Please stop.
Why are they still beating me up?
Why are they so... Alright.
Who wants to show me the next place?
Who wants to show me the next area?
Someone show me the next area.
Alright.
Ezer.
Wait where's Ezer?
That's not Ezer.
Wait where is Ezer?
Hahaha.
Where's the blue?
Oh wait no.
Where's the...
Oh there he is.
There he is.
Alright.
We're going to the next area guys.
Hahaha.
I forgot that...
I'm just getting like nipped in the back.
I forgot that the blue is Diamond Armor.
I thought it was just the mic.
I was like why are there so many people with blue skins?
It's really... A lot of these places I'm seeing for the first time.
Um... Because I never like toured this for the last... I think the last five... four days.
I haven't put... went on Minecraft for the last four days because I'm so busy prepping for all these guys.
It's a lot of things.
The hallway is so beautiful.
Thank you.
The hallway lasts three days of travel.
So get ready...
Oh my god!
Hahaha.
This is beautiful.
No fuck Twitch.
Hahaha.
I refuse to look at Twitch.
I see as I stream on Twitch.
Hahaha.
They rejected my partnership four times.
Oh!
Hahaha.
Is this everyone who was on the server?
Oh!
That's so cute.
That's...
Hahaha.
Oh!
There's a point on the...
There's like...
They're just beating easier up.
Hahaha.
And then there's media.
Oh!
Thanks for everything.
Are those buttons for eyes?
Do I have buttons?
Hahaha.
Can you press my eye?
Okay.
And then there's Tokidoys.
Tokidoys.
Oh!
And then there's fishies.
This is so cute everyone.
The free daily is on the free daily is on!
On the Montessar of the show Yeah!
I'm type of pony Every pony, every pony Should be popular as popular can be.
Making my mark, making my mark in high society.
I'm the girl of the Montessar of the show Yeah!
I'm type of pony Every pony, every pony Should hang on every word that I speak.
My approving glance is what they all seek.
I'm the creme de la creme Just needs another Jane doll.
Yeah!
I'm the type of pony Every pony, every pony Should hold me at the altar on a fancy yacht.
Come and talk, the talk of all canterlots.
I'm the creme de la creme Just needs another Jane doll.
Hahaha.
That's the name of pony.
Every pony, every pony Should know.
Oh, oh, oh, Yeah!
Pony,
pony, pony I'm type of pony.
Pony, pony, pony As popular as popular can be.
Making my mark, making my mark in high society.
I'm the girl of the Montessar of the show Yeah!
I'm type of pony.
Every pony, every pony Should know.
I'll be the talk of the town.
The girl on the floor.
I'm the type of pony.
Every pony, every pony Should know.
I'll be the one to watch the girl in the love.
I'm type of pony.
Every pony, every pony Should know.
I'll be the toast of the...
Toast!
I can't make this a dog!
I'm the type of pony.
Every pony, every, every Should know.
Every pony, every pony Should know.
In high society.
I'm as popular as popular can be.
Making my mark, making my mark In high society.
I'm the girl of the Montessar of the show.
Yeah!
I'm the type of pony.
Every pony, every pony Should know.
At the altar on the San Sion.
I'm the girl of the top.
The talk of all of Canterlot.
I'm the premedle, the premedle.
Just another chain dog.
Yeah!
I'm type of pony.
Every pony, every pony Should know.
Yeah!
Bop, bop, bop.
After an entire year of singing this song, I still don't know how to sing it.
I still can't memorize it.
I'm sorry!
Talk and toast!
It's all the same to me!
Little carrots.
After...
Where's Acer?
Okay, Acer, let's go.
Lead me to the...
Lead me to the new...
New area.
I can't believe...
After an entire year of singing that song non-stop, I still don't know how to sing it.
I still...
I still mess up!
It's always toaster talk!
Which could it be?
What?
Every time I think it's toast, it's talk.
Every time I think it's talk, it's toast.
Belle!
Also, Jeremy, thank you so much for the rate!
Thank you, thank you!
I really do appreciate it.
Also, look at this.
This is our map.
Oh, it shows up?
You can see the hallway!
The great hallway!
Wait, where's the hallway?
Oh, there it is!
Look!
Look, there it is!
And then it goes underground here.
And then it goes here.
And oh my god, it's actually it's so, so expansive!
This hallway!
What was I thinking?
Why did I do this to everyone?
Oh yeah, okay.
Okay, not gonna lie, the hallway's supposed to be a lot shorter.
And I realized, oh, free labor!
So then I made the hallway longer for everyone.
I was like, at first it was gonna end here.
It was gonna end here.
And then I was like, oh, everyone's gonna be helping me out!
So then I made it all the way here.
Isn't that beautiful?
It's like the land of Doki.
Alright, Acer, lead us to the next place to go.
I couldn't help it.
I was like, oh my gosh, I can make this hallway longer?
Because other people will work for free?
Where do we go?
Alright, the villagers through the hallway?
Alright, let's go in!
Let's travel!
Let's go in!
Oh my god, my chat!
It's so weak!
Alright, so this is the hallway.
It takes three to four days to travel through the entire hallway.
Like, not like actual days, but like um...
I like how you can just hear bop bop bop bop bop bop.
Like the click clack sound.
It takes longer!
The hallway ovens!
You can't attack me!
I'll put you in the hallway!
I'm gonna put you in the hallway!
Don't piss me off!
It's never ending.
This is gonna be a really long stream.
We're almost there, guys!
We're almost...
We're almost there!
Trust me!
I saw Sazer slightly descend into insanity.
Look, chat!
We're going down!
Clearly, we're getting closer!
We're getting closer, guys!
It's alright!
Ruby, it's alright!
Thank you for hanging out and dropping by, though.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you!
Wish your mom a happy birthday from me!
I'm from this random stranger on the internet!
Tell her I'm anime!
She'll understand!
laughter laughter laughter
Wait, you're right!
No, it's fine!
I look behind me and I see the trail of people!
laughter You said that and I accidentally turned too much!
I forgot it was the right way!
laughter No sane person will ever be able to get in.
Exactly!
Can't break into my house!
You gotta go through the hallway first!
It's okay, guys!
We're almost there, everyone!
We're almost there!
laughter Guys, it's okay!
Two days later, we're almost there!
Guys!
laughter Okay, just remember that before these trap doors, before these, like, trap door thingies, we had to open and close them manually ourselves.
And then people went crazy, so now there's these!
Now there's pressure plates.
I'm gonna find one and get to sit in a doki!
laughter So before, yeah, so before then, people were going crazy because they kept opening, we had to open and close the doors ourselves.
And people were like, Yeah!
No!
laughter They called pressure plates, yeah.
I know.
I know now.
Just remember, chat, my first time I ever, like, actually played Minecraft for, like, by myself, this was the first thing I did.
I made a hallway.
And this would be the last thing I do on Minecraft.
laughter This is the...
laughter Many trees and rocks have died.
Many mountains and trees have died for this.
Wait.
WAIT!
There's a hole in my hallway!
laughter Who put this hole in here?
Who robbed my house?
laughter There should not be any holes in this area, in this hallway.
laughter Now this hallway is ruined.
laughter Wait, am I going the right way?
I should be.
I am.
Yeah.
Oh, and then here, here.
Wait, why are there more more holes?
laughter So right here is, uh, right here is...
Am I going the right way?
Right here is... Wait, where am I?
Wait, where does this go?
Wait.
Oh, why is... Wait, where are the...
laughter Wait, where are the torches?
Guys, where are we?
laughter laughter laughter How did you afford all this lumber?
laughter You don't have to pay for labor.
It's okay.
laughter laughter Why are there no torches in here, guys?
Where are we?
I think we got lost already.
laughter laughter laughter Where are we?
Wait, did I go backwards?
Wait, is this...
This is the right way.
No, this is the right way.
We just have a hole.
There's no graduation allowed.
laughter laughter Why did I do... No graduation allowed.
I don't know which is the right way and which is the wrong way.
Why are some so dark?
It's like a spooky hallway now.
Oh.
Welcome to the...
Someone put some torches in here.
I don't know where to go.
laughter laughter Where does the hallway lead?
Ask for us to find out later.
You just need to look and you'll get out.
laughter I'm haunted.
Oh, wait.
This is your fault.
laughter laughter What was that famous... wait.
Did this just lead to a dead end?
Wait.
laughter Are we at a dead end?
laughter Wait a minute.
Why is there a dead end here?
laughter laughter Oh, no.
It's just we didn't open the door.
We didn't open the door.
Okay.
laughter laughter Hey, Siri.
Alright.
So, wait.
What was I gonna say?
I forgot what I was gonna say.
laughter laughter So, wait.
Why is there...
Why are there so many holes here?
Poor construction.
How dare my free laborers poorly constructed my hallway.
I do not understand.
laughter laughter
The holes are taking the view.
laughter No, that's not the point.
You're supposed to go crazy.
Not realize there's... you're supposed to think there's no outside anymore after going through my hallway.
After going through my hallway.
You're supposed to see that the outside doesn't exist anymore.
It's just doors.
I think everyone's like trying to figure out how to get out right now.
laughter laughter Oh, shit.
Okay.
This is a sky hallway.
This is a sky... Oh!
That's the quote.
I remember.
You didn't stop to think about... Oh, was it the scientist quote?
The scientist quote.
But that's... I am the scientist.
And now we're at the sky hallway.
You might not know this, but we're in the sky.
This sky hallway has taken many, many lives.
Chat.
Many lives have been lost here.
For this building.
Because it wasn't a very smart idea to build a hallway in the sky.
laughter laughter
I love the sky hallway view.
Isn't it beautiful?
It truly is.
You can almost see the clouds from up here.
Is this the only way we can stop to think if we should?
I see your spicy beans.
Alright.
Don't worry.
We're almost there.
Based on that one horror game you played.
And then...
I feel so so you're definitely not claustrophobic or trapped.
Of course!
Many Yamashis were harmed in the building.
Are there murder holes?
That's for you to find out when you go in the sky hallway.
laughter laughter
Now we're high I don't know if you realized that but we went up some stairs.
So now we're even higher up in the sky.
laughter laughter This is the spookiest jump scare imagine this is better.
Because you can actually go crazy in here.
laughter laughter You walked into the great hallway of Doki Land.
The long long hallway that takes more than three days to travel.
There's no stairs.
There's no alley from inside.
You just lose track of time.
laughter Are we there yet?
laughter How are you doing?
It's been going great.
Look there's a window now.
Now that's the other sky hallway.
laughter That's the other sky hallway.
laughter And there was our sky hallway.
Wait where am I?
A big circle.
laughter laughter Also Rocket thank you for the four months with Prime.
Thank you thank you.
Can we get some before we descend into more madness.
Can we get some more park nights real quick for Rocket for the four months with Prime.
Thank you thank you thank you.
Thank you thank you so much.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you thank you thank you.
This can't be good for your sanity.
Ah but you see here.
I was never seen in the first place.
laughter How long it says.
laughter laughter This is just torture.
Ah yes the final heist where I torture my community.
My entire community has to go through this.
laughter
This is my This is my final gift to you guys.
Who cares about the thing for the finals at the end of the stream.
This is my final gift to all of you.
laughter
This should be its own video game.
Nerd turtle thank you so much for the tier one for ten months.
Thank you thank you thank you.
Can we have some more park nights real quick for nerd turtle.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Thank you guys.
Thank you all for the final subs here.
The last sub.
Isn't that crazy.
This will be the last month where you get class from me.
The last day for class.
We're outside.
There is a door outside.
Oh my god.
There is an oh yes.
Oh okay I have a door outside for the bee.
This was my landmark.
This was my.
This is the bees dead though.
laughter
I went to the mountain.
It's the mountain end I made it specifically for the bee.
But someone killed the bee.
Then it wasn't me.
And it wasn't me this time.
Also senior spicy peen.
Thank you for the final month sub.
Tier one for three months.
Thank you thank you.
Can we get some more park nights.
Can we get some more park nights in chat for senior spicy peen.
Thank you thank you.
Thank you.
That really does mean a lot guys.
The final day.
Final month to use the park nights.
Thank you everyone.
Thank you.
Alright he was a fool.
And then wait this is sky hallway number two.
Sky hallway number two.
I know French.
laughter
Alright.
Let's go up number two sky hallway.
Why did I hear an explosion.
I just heard it.
There are two sky hallways.
Why were there.
Was there a creeper explosion.
Why are there several creeper explosions.
laughter Don't you just love the view from up here.
Don't you just love the view from up here.
laughter
Don't let Doki escape.
Not only.
Not only was there one skull.
Sky hallway.
There were two.
Before we do our graduation stream.
laughter That was the plan all along.
We never leave.
It's safe.
It's safe in here guys.
Come in.
Do not worry about the monsters outside.
Come in guys.
Come into the hallway.
laughter cough cough All for the sake of safety I am here.
What did I miss.
It's been 20-25 days and nights.
And we are still in the hallway.
laughter laughter laughter To escape.
We have hallways, doors, and dead bees.
laughter
I am scared now.
We are almost there guys.
We are almost there everyone.
What's wrong with this?
I don't understand.
Okay, I thought these guys were gonna fuck me, put me there.
And then this is my village that I've kidnapped.
I have...
This is my village now.
This village belongs to the hallway gang.
Someone else we kidnapped.
This is my hall.
This is Doki the hallway monitor.
Alright, am I supposed to go anywhere?
Here?
Am I supposed to go inside here?
Wait, what could my... I would have thought this was great when I...
Wait, where are they?
Where are the villagers?
Roy, what did you do to the villagers, Roy?
What did he... Oh!
Oh no!
That's what he did to them!
I have made them use free labor.
They've gone insane!
They've... Villagers are in captivity!
Oh, and now that they're reproducing here too!
They're making more villagers here!
Really?
They're imploring-The hallway broke them!
Alright This is all members of chat broken by the hallway!
The hallway has taken another victim I see So after that so now that we saw sky hallway, let me show you Let me show you ground hallway, underground..
Wait, underground!
No way!
Now we're underground.
You might not notice this, but we're underground now.
Zara, thank you for gifting us up the Spoonay!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you so much!
Here, get some Park Nights real quick for...
Here, get some Park Nights real quick for you, Zara.
For gifting us up the Spoonay.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
It really means so much.
Thank you guys.
Thank you so much, everyone.
Thank you, thank you!
Alright, guys.
So, yeah, this is the underground hallway.
Isn't this beautiful?
Look, you can see...
some water.
What the fuck?
You can see a little bit of water.
Isn't this beautiful?
And people are dying above me.
See, look at that!
We're in the hallway and we don't get attacked.
Look at that, guys!
We're in the hallway and we're safe!
This is safe!
This is safe zone!
This is a safe place!
I'm convinced the outside doesn't exist.
And now, not only do we have two hallways in the sky, we have three hallways in the sky!
We are on hallway sky number three!
A tree clip!
I realized there was really no point in making a hallway in the sky only because we can't even see the sky.
But hey, many died for building this.
Many lost experience points for this build.
Homicide, thank you so much for gifting a sub to the side machine.
Thank you, thank you!
Yabu is seriously slain by a zombie!
Thank you so much!
Can we get some more bark knights?
Real quick, for homicide, for gifting a sub to the side machine.
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you!
Thank you so much everyone!
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
Alright, let's go to...
Oh, it's raining, but we don't know that.
We're in a hallway.
We're almost there, guys!
I'm positive we're almost there now.
This is it!
This is the run!
Where am I?
Is this the end?
Is this the underground?
Oh, I'm going crazy?
Am I hearing voices?
That's...
When I heard voices, I was like what was that?
Am I actually going crazy now?
We're almost there, guys!
For sure!
We're definitely there!
So you probably were like Oh, thank you, Rocket!
That's really sweet, Rocket!
Since I don't graduate!
Alright, it's time for me to...
Okay, let me get the sub to you guys.
I've never done this before.
Oh, that's really sweet, Ruby!
I've never gifted a sub to my own stream because no one has ever redeemed this before.
But I will...
But I will do it.
Alright, should we...
I'll do like a gift... a sub.
Gift one sub.
Alright, here we go.
I'm doing it!
Who's gonna get it?
Who's gonna get the sub?
Congratulations, Vic!
Congratulations!
Can we get some Barth Knights real quick?
For myself?
For myself!
Please!
Barth Knights for me!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you, Mia, for gifting a sub!
No problem!
Alright, where was I?
Is this the right area?
It's here, right?
Which way?
Which way do I go, Ocelot?
I'm lost!
Which way, Ocelot?
Which way did I get lost?
Alright!
Alright, another gifted sub.
Into the world it goes!
Another one bites the dust!
Oh, two!
Alright, alright.
Who gets this one?
Envy!
Congratulations!
Another gifted sub, everyone.
Another one.
Alright, can we get some Barth Knights real quick for me again?
For me again?
Thank you!
For Shire Rose!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you to me!
And I guess Roy and Ruby for redeeming those!
Thank you, everyone!
Thank you, thank you!
And thank you, me!
Alright, where do we go?
Is it here?
Is this the right way?
Okay, this is the right way.
I lost track of all these gifted...
We've all won all the gifted subs.
Look!
There's a fourth sky hallway?
I didn't even remember!
That there was a fourth one!
But now there's a fourth sky hallway!
There were so many so many hallways, I've forgotten how many there were in the end.
And then...
Here we go.
Here, we're almost there.
I swear, guys, we're almost there.
We're almost there now.
For reals now, guys.
For real.
This is it!
This is it, guys!
The final frontier!
This is it!
No, I'm sure... and we're here!
And you're back where you started.
Hahaha!
This was my plan all along.
To make the whole...
So whenever someone spawns in, they'll be like, this is the right way to go, right?
And then they go through madness.
Am I going through this hallway?
Any new players that come in and they're like, oh, there's two doors here!
Do I go through here?
Or do I climb up?
And if they choose here, then they just go insane.
Then they just go...
Hahaha!
Then they just go insane.
And all I see is hell in one hallway.
Hahaha!
Rancid's been lost.
We lost someone in the hallway.
We've lost Rancid.
Can we get some...
Can we get some F's in chat for Rancid?
Hahaha!
Rancid can't go back!
Rancid has been lost in the hallway.
We don't know where he...
We have lost him!
Where is he?
Where did he go?
I don't even see his name anymore.
I think...
Hahaha!
Not everyone makes it out.
I mean...
Hahaha!
Not everyone can make it out in the... make it out of the hallway.
They're just gone.
Look down.
Is Rancid out?
RANCID!
He's out!
He missed...
He didn't!
Hahaha!
We spoke too soon.
He survived.
Hahaha!
But at what cost?
At what cost, guys?
Hahaha!
At what cost?
He's not the same ever since he got lost in the hallway.
He hasn't been the same again.
Hahaha!
Oh my gosh, Ruby.
Please!
Hahaha!
Was this all the...
Was this all the... everything at the server?
Not blocking out the hallway.
What can escape?
Was this everything at the server, Acer?
Is there more?
Was there more?
I don't know if there's any more.
Because like I said, I don't really know what you guys made here.
Other than um... um...
bits and pieces I saw while I was constructing the hallway.
Oh yeah, I love how like everyone else's like builds are so much nicer than mine.
Like I just have this.
I just have this.
Hahaha!
Wait, Sloth!
Was that your house in the middle of nowhere?
Like, was that your house all the way like in the mountains next to this this hallway?
Next to hallway number four?
Was that yours?
Hahaha!
I found a... there's a house like right here!
I found a random house in the mountains while I was... I don't know who the deranged man was.
Hahaha!
It took 30 minutes to... Oh, it took 30 minutes to walk you guys.
This was a...
This was a fucking 30 minute hallway.
Hahaha!
Hey, Acer!
Oh, that's crazy.
I can't believe...
Oh, that's yours?
Alright, let's go to...
Let's go to...
Let's go to Elsa... Not Elsa.
Hahaha!
Dragon's... Dragon's house.
Yeah, so...
What you guys don't know, I'll show you a little secret in Dragon's house.
So let me get there and I'll show you this little secret.
If not for the whole way pretending as... Hahaha!
Hahaha!
Alright, so you guys are looking and we go... You can have your own little tour to the hallway if you want.
Oh shit!
I'm sorry!
Hahaha!
Yoink!
Sorry dragon!
Sorry, my now!
Hahaha!
My now!
Sorry!
Hahaha!
It was an accident.
I just wanted to get up easier.
Okay, so let me show you a little secret.
Um...
With...
Um... With Dragon's house.
And it's very interesting.
Look at this doll... door hallway.
Truly beautiful.
Truly a sight to behold.
Alright, so this little secret that I'm gonna show you guys.
Oh my gosh!
Why are people talking in this song?
Hahaha!
Alright.
Boop!
This is good.
Uh...
A doorway?
Oh, so it's just this.
Alright, let me show you a little secret.
Uh... From his house.
So... Oh, what's this first?
What's this?
Oh, more stuff I can steal.
Tax time!
Hahaha!
Alright, so this little secret that I'll show you guys really quick is that if you...
Uh...
Where is it?
I'm trying to remember where it is.
Where this... Where this little secret is.
Hahaha!
Wait, what's this?
Oh, this was not the secret.
But that was interesting.
Alright.
I'm trying to find the secret.
There's a secret here.
I swear, guys!
There's a secret here that I made!
On accident.
Hahaha!
Oh my god, Michael!
Alright.
Where is this secret?
Oh, it's here.
It's here.
Trust me.
We're gonna find it.
Wait, where is it?
No!
I don't know where I put it!
Oh, it's here!
It's here!
This is my secret!
Hahaha!
This is my little... little hole.
Little hole behind his house.
Hahaha!
I accidentally mined into...
I accidentally mined into Dragon's house.
I didn't realize I was gathering more material for...
I was gathering...
more material for the hallway and I accidentally mined into Dragon's house.
I was like, what is this?
Also, I blew up one of his chests too.
Hahaha!
That's the other secret.
I blew up one of his chests.
Hahaha!
On a... by accident.
When, um...
When a creeper showed up next to me.
But it's okay.
I put everything back.
Do not worry, Dragon.
Everything...
Everything was back.
I put it back.
Hahaha!
So technically...
We all...
We all arrived at his house.
Hahaha!
And so you didn't lose anything, no?
You didn't lose anything.
Hahaha!
Alright.
Oh shit.
Alright, Michael.
Let me hydrate real quick and I'll do the Michael review.
Okay.
Here's another secret.
Uh, he had cobblestone in one of his chests.
And I might have taken some for the whole way.
Hahaha!
I was like, who lives here?
What a freak!
Oh, he has cobblestone.
Mine now.
Hahaha!
That's the only thing I took though.
That was the only thing I took.
That was...
I didn't want to mine more.
I was tired of mining.
I was just like, look at these cobblestones I found on the ground.
Look at that.
I found... Hahaha!
Hahaha!
Look at... Look at these cobblestones I found on the...
on the ground.
Wooo!
Hahaha!
Oh my gosh.
Okay, alright.
Let me...
Let me do the Michael review.
I'll eat a toast of the toast, the hosannacle I'm the type of toast, I ain't toast, I ain't toast, should not eat a toast.
Watch the toast in the flow.
I'm the type of toast every pony, every pony should know.
I'll be the toast of the toast.
The toast on the toast.
I'm the... I'm lost.
I'm lost.
I am so lost.
Hahaha!
I'm the type of toast, every toast, every toast should know.
And I'll be the one to watch the toast in the flow.
I'm the type of toast, every toast, Toast, every toast should know becoming as popular as popular as toast can be.
Making my toast, making my toast.
Alright, oh my gosh, I actually went insane there.
I think that fucked me up more than the whole way.
Alright, let's end the tour!
Yeah, fuck you.
How are we ending the tour?
Ah!
Oh, nope, no we're not ending with that.
How are we ending it?
What?
I simply shift too fast.
The egg is sad?
Why you sad, egg?
Why does it keep stopping?
This is my house now.
Look at that!
I'm safe!
Because of doors?
I don't need this.
Alright, is that it?
Is that how we end the tour, everyone?
Any final messages from my Minecraft tour?
My way through the hallway?
Oh shit, Acer, can you TP Ruby?
That's Ruby, right?
TP!
TP eggalore!
The Doki squad, woo!
This stream will never end, we're gonna be stuck in Minecraft forever.
We will be stuck here forever.
Alright guys, that was a great... a group photo?
Oh shit, yes, let's have a group photo!
Where should we have our group photo?
Let's have it... let's have it here!
So we can see the hallway!
We can see part of the sky hallway!
Let's have it...
Or next to Toma... no no!
Next to tomato!
Let's go to the tomato!
Let's all go to the mall today!
Also there's this.
What is that hot bar?
Let's all go to the tomato!
Someone's gonna die here.
We're gonna have the final group photo.
And then we're gonna do a little song request.
I feel like someone's gonna die here and it's not gonna be me.
Why did we all have that tomato?
Let's fight the ender dragon.
And then after that we're gonna do like a very very short karaoke song.
Of songs I've sung before.
Cause I am so sorry I haven't been able to prep like any new songs for you guys.
Cause I was just so busy with my work.
And I was just so busy with prepping everything for all of you.
And then here it is.
Alright so that means we gotta go...
Here!
For the photo.
Woah woah!
Woah woah woah!
Woah!
What?
Why am I
here?
Why?
And you...
You teleported everything!
My house!
My town!
Our beautiful town!
It's okay the tomato is still alive!
Oh my God!
It's okay!
The tomato is still there!
Alright.
Okay.
Other than the creeper right there.
Look at all this stuff.
Not the group photo we wanted, but it's the group photo we deserve.
What is this?!
Okay.
Oh my god!
Why did you TP me here, Acer?!
Acer, you flaked this creeper's ear!
Oh my god!
We're all scattered!
Look at all of us scattered!
We're like, we're just fucking running to the hallway!
To the hallway if you want to live!
To the hallway!
Everyone!
Wait, where's the hallway?
Wait, I lost it so many...
Oh!
It's okay!
This is what the hallway was for!
This is what it was for!
The hallway was built for this exact situation!
Anyway, let's take a... let's take a photo of the...
Hey, Machika!
Alright, let's take a photo of the...
Let's take a photo of the...
The Enderman!
Just don't look at the Enderman!
Just don't look at the Enderman and we'll be fine!
Are we good?
Just don't look at him!
Please!
I can't!
Please stop!
I looked at him!
Save me!
I hit the one thing I wasn't...
Please!
Save me!
What the fuck?
I... I wanted to...
It was one job.
Okay.
Alright.
Why am I in this home?
What happened to my bed?
Why am I in this stranger's home?
How did I get here?
Okay.
Have we taken the photo?
Have we done it?
I...
I didn't even realize I slept in everyone's home.
Alright.
Okay.
I was crazy once.
They locked me in a room.
A rubber room.
A rubber room with rats.
And rats make me crazy.
Crazy?
I was crazy once.
They locked me in a room.
A rubber room.
A rubber room with rats.
And rats make me crazy.
Crazy?
I was crazy once.
They locked me in a room.
A rubber room.
A rubber room with rats.
And the rats make me crazy.
Did we get the photo?
Did we... I can't believe it was Bully Ranger in the final stream.
Did we get the photo guys?
Oh we didn't?
Okay, okay.
Where's the tomato?
Let's get the photo again.
Let's do it again.
Whoever is doing the photo, come here.
So we can get the tomato in the background.
Are you house?
Dude, I don't know anymore.
This is it.
This is it!
Me...
and my bear skin.
This is it.
The final photo.
The final Minecraft photo.
Someone else do it.
I'm just standing here.
It's a 65%.
So not me.
I not do the photos.
Someone else do it.
I don't have the necessary buttons for it.
Who took the photo?
Or are we standing here forever?
Oh it has to be me?
Why?
Someone else do it.
Someone else do the photo.
Roy did it.
Roy.
We did it.
Roy did it.
Alright, I'm good.
Roy did the photo.
I'm good.
No, it's too much.
Too much work.
Just press F five times.
Press F five times.
Alright.
Now I'm here.
Are we good?
Did we do it?
Roy left.
So that means we did it, right?
We did it!
Woo!
That was our Minecraft server.
That was our Minecraft server, everyone.
Roy didn't even capture me.
I wasn't...
I wasn't even in the photo.
It's okay.
Okay.
I wasn't even in my own photo.
I wasn't...
We do this again.
Chad, I wasn't in my own photo.
How dare you, Roy.
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright, we're good.
Alright, alright.
Everyone, I'm leaving.
Look, I'm leaving.
I'm leaving.
Thank you, everyone, for coming to the Minecraft server tour.
And touring my hallway.
It was truly...
an experience.
I hope you all enjoyed the little Minecraft tour of the community server.
So, if you guys do not know, the server for those who will never be able to leave the Discord server, this Minecraft server will be here for for an entire month.
So, after that, after that, it's Azir's decision on what's gonna happen, cause he's the one that's running it right now.
So, thank you, everyone.
Yeah!
Get me!
I am poor now!
All the taxes I took from you are gone now.
Thank you, Casino!
Thank you for dropping by!
I really do.
Now you're all poor and I am rich.
Alright, everyone.
I shall go now.
Goodbye!
Alright, let me be right back real quick, guys, as we go back to the general... No, we go to the karaoke screen.
So, I'll be right back chat real quick.
I am back, everyone!
Let's put some jazz back on.
Let's put some... It's not over yet, Ninja!
You're just in time for this Doki Bird over the years.
Sadly, this was not done in Microsoft PowerPoint 2010.
Yamashii!
Thank you for the five gifted subs!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, Yamashii!
Can we get some... Also, Cory for the 100 biddies!
Thank you, guys!
Thank you!
Can we get some birthnights?
Real quick, real quick, guys.
Real quick for Yamashii.
Thank you.
And Princess!
We did two months at tier one!
Thank you, guys!
Thank you!
I also... Hi, Yuna!
I saw Yuna just popped in.
Thank you, thank you, everyone!
Thank you!
Thank you, everyone!
Alright, so... So, this is all PowerPoint where I'm gonna give you a little introspective.
Also, I like how tiny everyone is up there.
Look at how tiny Yamashii is!
Let me fix that.
So...
Let me give you a little... After this, we're gonna go through the marshmallows too, after this.
We're so into Nougatpops!
Alright.
So, this is DokiBird over the years.
I will... Zero!
Thank you for the tier one too!
Thank you, thank you!
More birthnights!
Everyone!
Thank you, Zero!
For the tier one!
Thank you, thank you, everyone!
Thank you, guys!
Thank you!
Thank you, everyone!
Alright, and also a little...
A little heart for you guys too.
We haven't had buttharts in a while.
Cause I couldn't think of the followers.
There's too many.
But here's all the followers too.
Have a butthart, everyone!
Alright, so...
Let me take you my history.
So, let me take you my history.
Before I start, please bear with me.
Cause, um, I was very young.
And...
And because I was very young, I didn't really have a sense of fashion.
You know, little kids, when they think like, Oh, this looks nice.
But it doesn't look nice.
I thought it looked nice, okay?
I thought it looked nice on me!
Alright, so...
So, let me show you.
In 2012, um, I used to have a twin.
I'm an only child now.
So...
So, I'm an only child now.
What happened to the twin?
Well, we'll never know!
We'll never know!
The twin got eliminated!
Who knows?
There's no evidence or proof!
I've always been a thief since 2012.
I've always been a... I can't see!
For some reason, I'm blind right now!
I can't see my chat for some reason!
Alright, I...
Alright, so...
So, I've always been a thief, but I wasn't...
I didn't have this outfit before.
So, this was my original outfit in 2012.
And I realized, hmm, maybe beige and blue doesn't go very well.
So, I went full blue a bit later.
As you see my ex-twin over there.
Can you see this?
It's so awesome!
But this was my very first outfit and my very first, like, how I like to see myself in 2012.
And I used to have braided pigtails.
And so, I was like, just twin tails.
I had braided pigtails instead.
And I realized, that's way too much work.
That's way...
That's way too much work.
Do you know how much work braiding is?
So, I...
I got rid of that.
So, now we have our little... our signature... Then I got lazy.
Then I...
Then I got lazy.
Two enter, one survive.
So, alright.
So, that was 2012.
Survival of the fittest.
Exactly.
So, in 2014, I got my new alternate outfit.
So, this one, you might recognize this one a lot more.
Um...
The twin's still here.
But don't worry.
In the next line, I became an only child.
So...
But in 2014, uh...
The twin was... My twin was still there.
My twin... My ex-twin was still here.
Don't worry.
He'll be gone... He'll be gone in the next year.
Never got...
He went into the hallway and never came back.
He went into the...
I don't seem very sad though.
But...
But that was my first alternate outfit.
So handsome!
So, that was my, uh... first alternate outfit.
And, um...
Um... This is a very recognized.
You can see the signature.
I've always kept the hat.
Uh... I've always kept my hat and my pigtails.
We don't... We don't talk about the... the braided pigtails.
We don't talk about that time.
That was cursed.
That was when I didn't have any sense of anything.
I don't know how to...
I don't know how colors work apparently.
He's left in my heart.
He's gone!
He got accepted, Link!
He got accepted!
He's gone forever!
What do you mean VTuber?
I've always been me.
I've always been me since 2012.
Since 2012.
It's always been me.
And then after that, I discovered the world of VTubing.
And then I lost my twin.
And then I lost...
And then I discovered the world of VTubing.
And then I lost my twin.
So...
That's a big gap.
It's because I kept my other outfit...
My other outfit for so long.
But then I realized...
This first model was done by Itzera.
Who you might know from Iron Vortex.
But this was before she was really in...
She was in Iron Vortex.
But this was before the guild was really popular.
It was before the big VTuber boom.
So I got a commission from Itzera.
But she was...
I wasn't through Iron Vortex at that time.
And...
And at that point, I was like...
Oh!
She gave me the design of...
My first model.
Back in...
She's getting milk chat.
He'll be back.
Yeah, he'll be back.
But I'm an only child, though.
He'll be back.
I'm an only child.
So...
I realized, I was like, well, it doesn't look... I realized even though that design, I really love my outfit back then.
I realized that it might have been too plain, I guess.
I was like, oh that's too plain.
Maybe I should spice it up a little.
Do whatever you want with the model.
Just spice it up.
Do whatever you want with my outfit.
Spice it up.
And then she added all these new stripes, the accessories, the pins and everything.
And I'm like, perfect!
Because I was like, I paid thousands to have this done.
I might as well add more.
I want more accessories!
Because it doesn't add more to the value.
The thing is, it didn't add more to the value.
So I was like, give me more!
I'm getting my money's worth.
And I was like, this is not worth a thousand.
So that was in 2020.
In 2020, that was us, your twin, the tomato.
Who knows?
I'm just an only child now.
What twin?
I never had a twin, guys.
What are you talking about?
I've just been solo the entire time.
What twin?
I don't see no twin here.
It's just me.
Where's the twin here?
Alright.
Never heard of them.
And then after that, after that, the 3D model.
So this was my first live 2D model.
And after the same year, I also got my 3D model for it.
Because I was like, wow!
I can have hand trackers?
Because this one was done by Rika and his guild, Artemis Clones.
And I got a 3D model because I wanted to use my hands.
And I was like, that was back when I was like, I want hands.
How am I going to steal people's money if I can't fucking stick it in someone's pocket and go, yoink?
She just turned her twin into a dog, Kappa.
And so, um...
So this was the first time, uh...
This was my first 3D model.
So, uh, was that.
That was done by, like I said, it was done by Rika.
And, um...
We had a lot of fun with this model.
We did a lot of things.
I feel like the only reason I used that model was to give all of you middle fingers.
And that was a good time.
I think that was the first thing I did with a new model.
I was like, guys, look what I can do.
Oh yeah, and that was when the butt hearts were born.
That was it.
Oh yeah, you're right.
This was how the butt heart was born.
Because I couldn't make a real part.
Like, my hands couldn't make a heart.
It just looked like a butt.
And that's...
And that's where it came from.
Yeah, and I was like, there's a little hole on top of the heart.
Like a little butt hole.
And that's where it came from.
Okay, the era of the butt hearts.
And then I don't remember what's after this.
What is after this, guys?
Ah!
The introduction of the first appearance of Mei Mei and Bao Bao.
Necklobuster!
Thank you for the tier one 47 month streak!
Can we get some...
Spark nights real quick for Necklo!
47 months!
Oh my god!
Thank you, Necklo!
So sweet.
It really is.
Thank you.
And some final butt hearts from the...
Spark nights!
Thank you, thank you!
I'm glad you had a great time with us.
A great journey with all of us.
Thank you.
It really does.
It does mean a lot.
Oh my gosh.
Oh gee!
It was back when I used to play Overwatch, too.
Back in my dark times in Overwatch.
Alright, so this was the very first appearance of Mei Mei and Bao Bao.
And...
It was actually by coincidence.
Because, okay...
Okay, the lore is that...
The lore...
I found them in the laboratory and I took them.
This was the very first appearance of Mei Mei and Bao Bao in July 2020.
And Mei Mei is the black rabbit and Bao Bao is the white one.
So you guys don't know which is which.
Because Mei Mei means sister and Bao Bao is just bun.
Because he looks like a little bun.
I just stole them from a lab.
It's okay, they're using up all my money.
They've been ordering Uber Eats everyday so that's cool.
Why do you think I'm always broke, guys?
Why do you think I'm always running out of money, everyone?
So that was the very...
very first appearance of my little bunny minions.
The very first time they appeared in my life.
And then these were the references from my 1.0 design.
I like to call this... well not 1.0, I'll call this 1.50.
This was the very first... these were the very first official references of my 1.5 design.
Left side was done by Heartpuff and the right side was done by WK4.
So they're both very talented artists.
And just a little... little... little...
little bit of bonus for all of you.
One of the first reference sheets I have.
One of the very first reference sheets I have of me, basically.
And then the next slide.
I think it's my alternate.
The alternate outfit!
I just want to notice a lot of people's favorites.
This outfit was a lot of people's favorites.
Slime 2.
So WK made me new clothes.
And I was like, I want 3D of this.
So I can move my hands with this too.
And it looks beautiful.
It should be beautiful.
Simply... simply...
Beautiful.
So I can walk out in public, you know?
Because I can't walk out like this all the time, guys.
I can't.
What the heck?
Like people will be like, that looks like a thief.
Hmm.
Why does she have traps everywhere?
That looks like a main character of a show.
So I have to...
I have to get another outfit done for myself so I can blend in.
I can blend in with everyone in the public.
So this was my very...
That looks like the other twin.
That outfit... no, it's like...
That can't be a thief.
She's wearing casual clothes.
She looks like a background character.
So that was the first...
Now I think this next slide, I have a feeling what it is.
And I'm gonna say...
What I'm gonna say is...
What could have been.
So I've been...
This one, I got this a while ago.
Like a long... a long...
Not a while ago.
I was like...
I don't remember when I got this.
But this was a little bit ago.
But before I got contacted by the bank team...
I had a little...
I had a little thing I wanted to do.
Like with my extra cash.
So I was paying this off slowly by slowly.
And it was like with my extra cash I have that saved up.
So like I would put a little bit.
And I...
My dream was to like...
So let me show you what it is now first.
Let me show you.
Oh wait, no!
This is 2.0!
Okay.
Alright, this is 2.0!
I was...
I clearly forgot myself.
I forgot myself, guys.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I forgot about Clea.
It's hard when I'm already here.
Like why am I over there?
Why am I over there, guys?
When I'm here?
Alright.
I'm sorry, Clea.
I have too many identities, guys.
I can't remember all of them.
And now there's four of me?
Why are there so many of me?
Don't worry.
I'll be an only child again soon.
So this is...
I feel like I talked about Clea...
The one I went with Clea.
I talked about this before.
For the debut graduation stream.
So I'll make...
I'll make this a bit more quick.
Because a lot of this was already talked about during the...
graduation announcement stream.
The re-debut slash graduation announcement stream.
But I went to Clea for 2.0.
2.0.
Because I was like, RieDoki is the...
twin.
So at first, we went with...
It was between the red and the blue color scheme.
Because the original design was inspired by the Vocaloid song.
Phantom Thieves.
Phantom Thieves song from Vocaloid.
And they're twins.
I'm an only child.
So...
I decided to go with the blue.
Because the blue and the gray.
Because I felt like that matches well...
With the original...
Colors.
With the original colors.
And I felt like...
I feel like wearing red...
Would make me much more noticeable in public.
Like, where did she go?
Look at this bright red color in the crowd.
Is that her?
So I was like, maybe gray is better.
I don't know.
Maybe.
It's like, where did she go?
It's okay.
The only person that's wearing red is right there.
The each one performed the reverse mitosis.
So it was better for camouflage too.
The blending in...
Blending in with the crowd and everything.
And then we all know about my Cheeto bag over there.
Where I store my lock picking stuff.
Cheetos.
And my mic.
My mini miniature mic.
I had the tomatoes things.
The merchant.
I had the...
Okay, now I think the next slide is the one I was going to talk about.
So what could have been?
This is... next one is what could have been guys?
What could have been before the bank team caught me?
Before the bank team caught me.
So what could have been?
So my... before my... before I had that graduation announcement.
My plan was to... I love collecting.
I love collecting pictures of myself because I'm a narcissistic.
Because I'm narcissistic.
I love myself.
So I think we all know how much I love collecting artwork and different clothes of myself.
So my plan before my graduation was...
Was that...
Was that I wanted to collect outfits from different artists around...
Different like amazing artists around.
So I wanted to have like a little collection of outfits and stuff.
From like... instead of like alternate outfits, I just have...
Alternate outfits.
You guys know what I mean?
You guys... you guys know what I mean?
Alternate... alternate universes.
But that was... I was saving... so...
This... what... this... it never got... I never got rigged.
So... I only got to the point of getting the model or my outfit.
So at that point I... it was going to be done by Iron Vortex and Artgun.
Like a... between the two.
But what could it have been?
And we had Itosan.
I was going to drink from Itosan.
We were going to have like... Itosan...
Yeah, because all my... all my faces and clothes were clip-ons, guys.
Don't you remember?
I could have just easily clip-on a different outfit and a different face.
Easy like that.
Just... just take off... just... just take off my clothes.
Just take off my clip-ons and then clip another.
Pop.
Into the Dokiverse we go!
So...
This is the Doki Cinematic Universe, guys.
The Doki Cinematic Universe.
So some of you guys might have been...
Some of you guys might have been confused about like...
Oh, where... I had this outfit shown around... in like different assets.
So like my B-Rite back screen has that outfit on.
So you guys might have been like...
Where did that one come from?
But that was what could have been.
What could have been.
And then there was Ito-san and there was gonna be like flowers coming out.
And like...
And then Question might be like...
But instead of that I get like...
So...
And then we can have the little bunnies can like ride along in incognito mode.
Because they... people will think they're just bags.
But no, no, no!
I don't know what they are but...
At least people will be freaked out about...
them moving.
So yeah, that was what could have been guys.
What could have been.
And we have a few more slides left.
We have a few more slides left.
So after that...
After that...
Well, I'm gonna talk about the different...
Let's just look back at the different merch I've got of myself.
That I solely own because I'm a narcissist.
I'm a narcissist!
What can I say?
I love to hug a pillow of myself.
A little tiny pillow of myself.
There's only one that exists.
There's only one that exists out of all of these.
I also have a paper puppet.
This was done...
This paper puppet was done during my 1.0 outfit.
So it was a while ago.
The person...
I'm trying to remember his name.
But...
But he...
It was before he like blew up.
So it was very...
It was like he wasn't like super popular back then.
It was like...
It was 1.0.
So it was around like 2018, 2019.
Ish era.
So I was very fortunate to get one from him.
Yeah, it's like...
It is...
There's a video of it I posted on Twitter somewhere.
I don't remember.
But...
It's somewhere out there.
And now...
You got so many...
Yeah, I got so many around that time.
Because I didn't know what to do.
I mean...
I love myself so much.
I just wanted so much.
I don't know.
I love myself.
And then after that, it's...
Some of the little figures of myself.
Some of the little mini-me's of myself to look around.
So these are like little mini figures.
All of these are like...
Other than the acrylic stand.
The acrylic stand on the right.
That is given...
I think Ninja will have, will get the...
Because I only have two in the world.
I have two copies of this.
And one is for me and the extra one will be going to Ninja for his donation to the charity.
And then...
And then Foodbanks of Canada charity.
That's...
Ruby, thank you for giving us all the Sloth Guy!
Thank you!
Can we get some Bargnights really quick for Sloth Guy?
Thank you, thank you.
And Ruby for giving us all.
Thank you so much!
Thank you everyone!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you guys.
It does mean a lot.
Thank you.
But yeah, they're really cute.
I think the one in the middle is done by Claypuffs.
The one in the right is done by... let me look... I should have wrote down the names.
But I was in a rush.
I did this PowerPoint today, by the way.
But everyone's done by Spacethumb.
So all of them, I retweeted them.
I retweeted the artists too, of them, on Twitter.
And the last one to the left is done by Korean Figure Artist.
He's like... I don't know.
He's been gone on the internet for a while.
So... I think he got drafted into the Korean Army.
So that's why he's been inactive.
Yeah, he painted it on stream too.
He painted it on stream and everything.
It was so fun to watch.
I think I raided him.
I raided him while he was working on the figure.
It was great.
He's with your twin.
Also, BigDuck, thank you so much for gifting a sub to Lurker.
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you.
Can we get some more Park Nights in chat?
Also, hey, Next.
Thank you, thank you.
Can we get some more Park Nights in chat for BigDuck for gifting a sub to Lurker?
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, guys.
I really do appreciate it.
Hey, Seri.
Alright, the last two slides.
We have two more slides left, guys.
Two more slides left.
So, after this, let's talk about the merch.
The merch that we had.
Our little shop that we opened for 30 weeks.
I just want to say thank you again for all of you guys for pre-ordering the merch for these.
Like, I honestly did not expect it.
I didn't expect to get as many as I thought I did.
In my head, I thought that I was going to get 20 at best.
I was going to get 20 orders.
And that was me, like, aiming high.
That was me being like, oh, I'll be lucky if I get 20.
And I actually thought that.
I actually thought that.
And then, I even, like, when I opened pre-orders, I was like, hmm.
If I just order 20 now, maybe I can, like, as I open the pre-orders, I was like, oh.
And if I order 20 now, maybe I can get them before my final stream.
And so, I did that.
And then, you guys, you guys, 50 orders.
I got 50 orders in the end.
I actually couldn't believe it.
And while you ordered the big bundle, too, I was like, oh my god.
So, I kept, like...
At first, when I hit, like, 30, I, like, um...
I, like, DM'd the manufacturer.
And I was like, hey, about that 20 orders, can you add, like, 10 more?
Like, 15 more?
And then, we all must rob a big review.
So, I was like, I was like, oh, shit.
I was like, can you put, like, 15 more?
Like, there's no way I'm going to get above 35.
There's no way.
And then, we went to 50.
And I had to contact them again.
And I was like, hey, about that.
I have more.
I have to order more.
I was like, there's no way I'm going to get above 35.
And I'm like, hey, I need, like, 15 more.
So, I kept...
The shipping for it kept getting pushed back.
And, um...
It kept getting pushed further and further.
Because I was supposed to get shipped, like, two weeks ago.
And it's because I kept adding more inventory.
That it got pushed back to, like, next...
Like, it's going to get shipped to me next week.
But don't worry.
I gave them the address to the Motel 6 that I'm going to be living in.
So, do not worry, Chad.
Do not worry.
And if I get internet service, maybe I'll try and post a little sneak picture.
Don't worry.
They won't know where I am.
There's 20,000 Motel 6s in the world.
I'll go to Motel 7.
Oh, my gosh.
Will, thank you so much for the three months of Tier 1.
Can we get some birthnights?
Real quick for Will.
Thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
I really do appreciate it, guys.
Thank you so much for the support for this final stream.
It's hot.
We're almost getting closer to the end, guys.
There's, like, two more things left on my little list of things I want to do for my final stream.
And we're getting there.
We're getting there.
Oh, my gosh.
Yeah!
Thank you, everyone.
Oh, my gosh.
Let me hydrate for that.
Let me...
Okay.
According to all knowns of aviation, there is no way a bee should be able to fly.
Its wings are too small to get its fat little body off the ground.
The bee, of course, flies anyway because bees don't care what humans think of them.
It's impossible.
Yellow, black, yellow, black, yellow, black, yellow, black.
Oh, black and yellow.
Let's shake it up a little.
Barry!
Breakfast is ready.
Coming!
Hang on a second.
Hello?
Barry!
Adam?
Can you believe this is happening?
I can't!
I'll pick you up.
Looking...
Shock!
Arp!
Use the stairs!
Your father paid good money for those.
Sorry!
I'm excited!
Here's the graduate!
We're very proud of you, son!
A perfect report card!
All bees!
Very proud!
Mom!
I got a thing going here!
You got lint in your fuzz!
Oh!
That's me!
Wait to us!
We'll be in row 118,000!
Bye!
Barry, I told you!
Stop flying in the house!
Hey, Adam!
Hey, Barry!
Oh, fuck you guys!
Is that fuzz dough?
A little!
Special day!
Graduation!
Never thought I'd make it!
Oh, my God!
Three days grade school, three days high school!
Those were...
Rage!
I'm glad I took a day and hitchhiked around the hive!
You did come back different!
Hi, Barry!
Artie?
Growing a mustache?
Looks good!
Hear about Frankie?
Yeah.
You going to the funeral?
No, I'm not going.
Everybody knows, sting someone, you die!
Don't waste it on a squirrel!
Such a hothead!
I guess he could've gotten out the way.
I don't know.
I love this.
Incorporating amusement park into your day?
That's why we don't need vaccinations!
Boy!
Quite a bit of pomp under the circumstances!
Well, Adam!
Today we are men!
We are!
Bee men!
Amen!
Hallelujah!
Students?
Faculty!
Distinguished Bees!
Please welcome, Dean Boswell!
Welcome!
New High City graduating class of 1915!
That concludes our ceremony and begins your career at Honex Industry!
Welcome!
Dean Boswell!
We pick our job today?
I heard it's just orientation!
Hands up!
Here we go!
Keep your hands on talent and sign on talent all times!
Wonder what it'll be like?
A little scary.
Welcome to Honex, a division of Hone's Cone and a part of the Hexagon Group!
Up!
This is it!
You have worked your whole life to get to the point where you can work your whole life!
Honey begins when our valley and pond jogs bring the net critter to the height!
We are the best!
Our top secret formula is automatically color corrected, sign adjusted, and bubble contoured into the soothing sweet syrup of its distinctive golden glow you know as Honey!
That girl was hot!
She's my cousin!
She is?
Yeah we're all cousins!
Right, you're right.
As Honex, we constantly strive to improve every aspect of eating existence.
The Bees are stress testing a new helmet technology.
Technology.
What do you think he makes?
Not enough.
Here we have our latest investment, the Kremlin.
What does that do?
Catches that little shroom of money that hangs out the port.
Saves us millions.
Can anyone work on the Kremlin?
Of course!
Most bee jobs are small ones.
But bees know what every small job, if it's not well, means a lot.
But choose carefully because you'll stay in the job constantly trying to improve every aspect of bee existence.
These bees are stress testing a new helmet technology.
What do you think he makes?
Not enough.
Here we have our latest investment, the Kremlin.
What does that do?
Catches that little shroom of money that hangs out the port.
Saves us millions.
Can anyone work on the Kremlin?
Of course!
Most bee jobs are small ones.
Okay, I'm closing the... I'm closing her damn...
You guys went too far.
It just kept going.
I'm closing it.
Too much.
It's too much.
I was like, no more.
No more.
Now no one has channel points.
Now no one has channel points anymore.
Think about your actions now.
I have... in the end, this was the heist all along.
This was the heist all along, guys.
This was the... this was the true heist all along, guys.
The true and final heist to end all heists.
To end all heists.
Alright.
Because of this, I will read all the other ones that we had left.
I will... I will read the rest of it.
Oh my god.
Like, I don't even know where I was.
Alright.
She's my cousin.
She is?
We're all cousins.
Right, you're right.
At Honux, we call me Popo.
We constantly strive to improve.
Through every aspect of bee assistance.
These bees...
Oh wait, am I reading this again?
Oh, she's not.
Let me skip the...
Wait.
Okay.
What do you think you make?
Not enough.
Well, here we have our latest...
Our latest...
Advancement.
The Kremlin.
What does he do?
Catches a little strand of honey that hangs after you.
Pour it and saves us millions.
Can anyone work from the Kremlin?
Of course.
Most bee jobs are small ones.
But bees know that every small job, if it's done well, will be worth it.
Well, it means a lot.
But choose carefully, because you'll stay in the job today.
I heard it's just orientation.
Heads up.
Here we go.
Keep your hands and antennas inside the tram at all times.
When it'll be like...
A little scary.
Welcome to Honux.
A division of Hon's Cone.
And a part of the Hexagon Group.
This is it.
Wow.
We know that you, as a bee, have worked your whole life to get to the point where you can work for your whole life.
Honey begins when our values are high.
And we get pollen drops to bring the nectar to the hive.
Our top secret formula is automatically color correct.
Today we are men.
We are men.
Bee men.
Amen.
Hallelujah.
Students.
Facilities.
Faculty.
Distinguished beings.
Please welcome Dean Busbell.
Welcome new hive graduating class of 1950.
That concludes our ceremonies.
And begins your career at Honux Industries.
Will we pick our job today?
I heard it's just orientation.
Heads up.
Here we go.
Keep your hands and antennas inside the tram at all times.
Wonder what it would be like.
A little scary.
Welcome Honux.
This is your institution of Hong Kong.
A part of the Hexagon Grow.
Reacted scent adjusted and bubble contoured into the soothing sweet syrup with a distinguished golden glow.
Known as honey.
That girl was hot.
She's my cousin.
She is?
Yes, we're all cousins.
Right.
You're right.
At Honux, we constantly strive to improve every aspect of bee existence.
They be bee, honey.
We are stress testing a new helmet technology.
What do you think he makes?
Not enough.
Here we have our latest advance with the Kremlin.
What does that do?
Catches a little strand of honey.
After you pour it, it saves us millions.
Can anyone work on the Kremlin?
Of course.
Must be.
Just know that every...
She's my cousin.
Your cousin?
We're all cousins.
Going in circles.
Oh, I can't remember reading the same part.
What is this?
I have to pull it out.
Yes, I have to pull it out.
Because people keep following.
So I kept reading the same thing over and over again.
Because I kept...
We're done here.
We remain on here.
You're all cousins.
Oh my god.
I've been broken.
This is payback for the holiday.
Oh my god.
What do you mean I have to keep... I already finished it.
I just kept reading the same thing over and over again.
I already finished this like 20 million.
Wait, are you worried?
Alright, Flychan, where are we?
Flychan, there's so many.
I don't know which one's you.
Where is it?
Wait, where is it?
I saw it.
What did you redeem?
No!
Alright, there we go.
Also,
Geek Girl, thank you for giving a 3 month tier 1 sub to Goh.
And Look, thank you for subbing for 9 months at tier 1.
And Geek Girl, thank you for 2 months at tier 1.
Thank you, thank you!
Can I get some Barf Nights?
Or a little quick.
For all the subs.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you everyone.
Thank you so much.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you guys.
Thank you all so much.
Thank you everyone.
It really does mean a lot.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you all!
Thank you so much!
You guys deserve, you guys deserve that for making me do the loop.
For making me do the loop.
It says they're open.
They seem exhausted for me.
You could have stopped and we all could have had our point.
But no!
No!
We're all cousins!
Alright.
Now we're all cousins!
Wait, what?
Yeah, you guys 100% touched the entire Instagram.
That was the final heist.
That was it!
Oswald, thank you for the sale!
Fuck yeah!
Joke's on you!
Chat's hiding your donation!
So I can't see the... I can't see what you wrote there!
You mad lad!
Ah, the way of the thief.
But I knew what... I saw the aviation laws and I knew...
I saw the aviation laws poking at the top.
I can't believe it.
I still like that.
Oh my gosh.
Also, there's still one more slide.
The final heist is about to end.
But not yet!
It's almost close.
We have two more things.
So one of the things I was gonna do...
One of the things I was gonna do is the...
Is the...
Marshmallows!
It's the marshmallows, guys.
You thought I forgot about the marshmallows?
So... Oh my god!
There's a lot of marshmallows!
I didn't think I would get this many.
I honestly...
Didn't.
Let's read them.
I will not cry!
I promise!
I won't cry, guys.
I won't.
I won't, guys.
Oh...
Let me hydrate real quick before I...
Before I cry all...
Cry all of it out.
Before I cry all of it out.
I'm gonna try not to cry.
I'm gonna try not to cry, guys.
We're gonna...
We're gonna try not to cry, guys.
Alright.
Marshmallow.
Okay.
So...
So here's the marshmallow.
Let's read this together, chat.
Let's read these... I have to refresh it.
Alright, guys.
I'm trying not to cry!
Alright.
Alright, guys.
Ahh, guys!
24... I didn't expect that many.
I didn't know what to say here, but it's only been a few weeks since I found you.
I'm not good with words and I'm really shy.
So for me, it's so difficult to talk with people.
But I really enjoyed every stream this last weeks.
You really made me smile so many times.
All my problems disappear when you hear your laugh.
Ahhh!
I'm really sad that you're graduating.
I'll miss watching you.
I'll miss the bark nights.
And I'll miss staying late and sleeping only one hour!
You're welcome!
Thank you, Doki.
Thank you!
Why did Rotten Tomato always felt left out?
Because he couldn't catch up.
Yeah, I know.
Finishing with tomato pun is not the best, but I really wanted to say it.
Aww... It's okay!
My VODs are still... Well, my VODs on YouTube are still up!
Just listen to...
If you record it and put it in like... If you have a Doki Makura, record my laugh, put it in the Doki Makura, and then it's like I'm always there laughing at you.
With you.
Alright, let's go to the next... Please someone do it!
You're always laughing at me.
Aww, phantom!
That's really sweet.
That was a really sweet marshmallow.
I'm not... I just met you, but it feels like I missed... It's okay as long as like you were there now before I was gone.
You were there when I was alive.
When I was live.
I'm always alive.
I'm not great with words, or at least emotional ones.
Your streams have helped me keep me sane through the ups and mostly downs of my life for the past two years.
Thanks for being the coolest burp.
No, thank you guys.
It really... You know, you guys also cheer me up so much too.
Whenever I have like a bad day, um, and then I would be like, should I really stream?
No, I feel like shit right now.
And as soon as I turn the stream on, I just feel so much better hanging out with you guys, just talking.
I think this is only, um...
This is why I always do a lot of chatting streams too.
Definitely I do a lot of like chatting streams and a lot of just like chilling.
Like, you guys like know to see how my art stream is mostly me talking.
Because I love talking to you guys.
I love talking with the community and just like hanging out.
And have you enabled my dumbass... dumbass chaotic lives.
Like...
You guys enabled me.
And it makes me happy.
It makes me happy.
But thank you guys.
So you guys do as much as you want.
As much as I do for you guys.
You guys make me happy and I'm happy that I make you guys happy.
Doki-chan!
I wanna say thank you so much for bringing me smiles, laughter, and lots of warmth for so long.
You really do brighten up my day and made me believe that I could be the best that I can be.
I don't know if my words will reach you in time, but just know that not a day goes by without me thinking of you.
And I give you all my wonderful wishes.
You stole my heart the day I crossed paths with you.
And although I'm quiet in the lurking shadows, I've witnessed an amazing growth of love and passion in the passage of time.
I'll feel empty about you by our side, but know that you changed our lives for the better.
Please remember us whenever you are and remember the love that you shared with us.
We will always share back.
X a thousand.
Thank you for inspiring me.
Thank you for all the wonderful things that you shared with us through this team.
I'll always admire and look up to you as an artist, as a community leader, and a creator.
We will always stay as a loyal Fortnite through and through.
Oh my god.
I'm not crying.
I'm holding it in till the end.
Guys.
Oh gosh.
That was so sweet.
Whoever wrote that one.
But no, like I said.
You guys make me so happy too.
You guys do.
I think this is also why I do not collaborate a lot too.
I feel like I'm one of the few, like one of the VTubers that don't really do a lot of collaboration streams.
Cause all I really want to do is just hang out with my chat.
And I feel like when I do collaboration streams, I'm not focusing too much on my chat.
I feel like, oh, my attention is not really on my, my chat now when I collaborate.
And honestly, I feel so much happier just talking to my chat.
Than like collaborating with other streamers.
Um, so it's like, you guys just make my day so much.
And I always feel bad when I'm like, oh, I'm ignoring chat.
I'm ignoring chat.
I just want to hang out with them instead.
And it's just, ah, thank you guys.
Thank you.
It really does mean a lot.
It really does.
Alright, let's go to the next one.
Why do you stitch chat into a single mantra?
It's being collaborated with.
Hey, Doki.
When I first found your stream through a raid, it was when you had taken off your skin and shooting your true colors as a, as a tomato.
At first, I found the concept of a tomato V2 refabulous.
So I stayed and laughed myself for a while.
But I just listened to your content, humor, and most especially your laugh.
I decided to stay and watch.
Never had I ever thought about my decision as a bad one.
And I doubt I ever will.
Finding your stream was damn well one of the best things to happen to me.
But only a week after watching your stream, you were announcing your graduation.
It felt awful seeing that.
The new light that I just found was so fleeting.
I was in a pretty big rut.
And it felt awful.
I don't know if I would still be here to mourn for you.
But I guess I can count as a blessing that I found you at all, huh?
But I won't beg and plead you to stay.
I just want you to wish that you have the best of luck in your future endeavors.
And that you just remember us.
Of course I'll remember you guys!
I'll never forget the Berk noise.
Chat.
You guys, we have people hearing from all the way from 2017.
Like, I'll never forget any of you guys.
Do not worry.
Do not worry, guys.
I always recognize people from my chat.
Like, every single one of you.
And I'm so happy that I changed some of your lives for the better.
Like, I think like...
Um...
Hahaha.
Some of the streams I do, my main thing is just to make you guys laugh.
Because that's all I want to do.
Make people laugh.
I love making people laugh.
Because it's like...
I know what it's like to feel...
To feel down.
And I always want to make someone laugh and have fun.
And I'm so happy that you guys feel that.
Feel the effort I bring out to all of you.
I'm trying not to cry!
But I'm tearing up now!
I'm trying so hard!
Hahaha.
Doki, my beloved.
You mean so much to me.
And I really mean that with every fiber of my being.
Thank you for letting me be a part of your community.
And inspiring me artistically.
And making me laugh when I wasn't having the best day.
It means so much to me.
And I will treasure every moment I've had in your streams.
Thank you and good luck with your future.
Felicity Machika.
Machika!
Thank you for that message.
Thank you so much.
I'm so happy that you enjoyed your time with the community.
I'm so happy a lot of you.
I'm really happy with the community I built.
I really am.
All the dumb stuff I came up with.
The Bark Knights.
The Tomato Squad.
All the Doki Squad.
It was just like on the fly things.
And then we kept these jokes up for so long.
For these names for ourselves.
And these jokes for ourselves.
This inner circle.
This inner community thing we had together.
Our claps.
Our little dumb brain cells gimmicks.
I'm so happy that the Doki Squad.
Anything for the Doki Squad.
I'm just so happy that we kept those.
Many of these jokes were like years.
Something that we came up with for years.
And something that was on the fly.
Thank you everyone.
It really does mean so much.
We were able to keep this community.
Through so long.
And please hydrate right after graduating.
How about that?
Good.
Good idea.
A little intermission there.
I'm not educated for math and reading.
Fuck reading.
I'm not reading.
Someone else is.
Wait.
Guys.
I just learned how to read.
I learned how to read for this particular stream.
It's a miracle!
I learned how to read guys.
My character arc has finally been complete, everyone.
We have finally completed our character arc.
I learned how to read.
Finally!
I can re-chat!
I was learning to read.
What did she forget after?
She did it!
I did it!
The Bee Movie taught me my ABCs.
We're all cousins now.
I really hope you have a happy and healthy life moving forward.
And doing what you do will never forget you.
I'll never forget you guys too.
Do not worry.
I'll never forget you guys.
You grow up so fast!
You finally passed first grade!
Hey Doki, even though I didn't know you long, I really enjoyed your streams the past month.
You're really such a welcoming and kind person.
You have so much energy in your stream, no matter the situation.
I love your laugh, it's seriously contagious too.
Oh yeah, and your thieving skills?
Second to none.
Yep, where are their points now?
Gone.
A beautiful heist.
I appreciate for not only...
I appreciate for...
Clearly my reading skills have not been that great.
I already lost track of where I was.
I appreciate for not only what you do, I appreciate for the impact you have brought to the community, but the impact you've left on all of us.
I want to work harder and bring the kind positivity you brought to not...
to... not to us?
To... to... to...
Oh, brought on to us!
I was like...
Brought on to us.
Big or small, best of luck in your future plans and stay on the run you sneaky thief.
Thank you from a forever Park Night.
AHHHHH!
I'm sorry for...
For like loosing...
Slowly loosing my reading skills there.
Miss Angel.
My reading skills...
Slowly deteriorated there.
I was like...
Where...
Where did it go?
Thank you.
Thank you everyone.
Thank you...
That was my message.
Thank you for being so...
Thank you Jay for this message.
Thank you again.
It really means a lot guys.
They are all your messages.
So I didn't want to...
Press on you.
It really means a lot that you guys take your time out to write a personal message to me.
It really does.
Thank you everyone.
We have been following you for a little while.
But I'm so glad I caught a few of your streams.
Can't help but smile and laugh every time.
Thank you.
That was my goal.
I honestly...
Every time I started my stream, my goal was just to make you guys laugh.
That's all.
And then I realized...
Man...
I'm starting to get angry.
Because of Apex.
I was like...
Guys, we're gonna have to stop.
Because all I want to do is make you guys laugh.
I don't want to be angry.
I want to be happy and funny.
Because I'm funny.
And if I'm not funny, I make you guys laugh.
Because my laugh forces you to.
I can make dumb jokes funny.
If I laugh.
Truly an amazing power...
Truly amazing...
I'm in the tier 1...
Brawly!
Thank you for the sub at tier 1!
Thank you, thank you!
Can we get some Bark Knights for real quick?
For Brawly, for the tier 1 at 1 month.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I really do appreciate it, guys.
Thank you so much.
Can we get some Bark Knights real quick?
Thank you!
How is everyone gonna know that you are the pony?
That you should know if you don't stream anymore?
I swear, even after you go, if you don't listen to the daily song every day, then you have failed me.
That is my dying wish to you all.
You guys better be listening to that song every day.
Or I will know.
I'll find out.
And I'll take your Bark Knight badge away.
You see me and I'm so humble.
While we didn't know each other for so long, I enjoyed spending my time watching your streams and hanging out in Overwatch.
I will always be proud to be a Bark Knight.
Oh, thank you Steve.
Thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you guys.
No, no, no.
I'm not dying.
I never die, guys!
That was just a lie.
Because I'm a thief.
But it's okay.
I'll tell you when I'm lying, okay?
But that way, I'm not dying.
I'm not lying.
People lying shake my head.
Alright.
Okay, Jake.
Thank you for hanging out with us.
I really appreciate it, Jake.
I hope you have a good night's rest.
Whatever you're doing the rest of the day.
Have a good day.
Thank you for coming by.
Thank you.
Alright, what's the next one?
I know I've only been here for a few months.
We will never have October month!
We will never have spooky month again!
I was like, I will never have to play spooky games again.
No more spooky mansion.
Portal wasn't a horror game.
More so of like, I just devolved into a caveman at the end.
All I could do was just up, down, and up.
Up, down, where do I go?
Mike, thank you so much for the raid!
Thank you!
I hope you had a great stream playing Resident Evil Village.
Holy shit, you played it... what difficulty did you play?
I heard the difficulty in the... what was it?
The village difficulty or whatever?
I heard that one was really really hard and people just rage quit at the Lady D part.
When she's like... when... that part.
I don't want to spoil, but a lot of people rage quit at the Lady D part.
For the hardest difficulty.
I saw one guy when he was at a boss fight for Lady D.
He spent like 6 hours on the boss fight and then he gave up and went to medium mode.
And he gave... and for like 6 plus hours he gave up and then like swapped to medium.
He replayed the game all the way... he restarted the entire game.
Because he was like, why not?
How do you play Big Bang Mario?
I think we all know how we all feel about Miss Lady D.
Okay, Mrs. Donkey, you have so many of my tends to call the channels I follow to a manageable size.
You are so right because of how happy you always seem to be.
Ohhhhh.
Oh, that's really sweet, Paul.
That really is sweet.
Alright.
So, I'll be like...
Thank you, Amy, for the great times, memories, and streams.
Your laughs are amazing and always lift my spirits.
You've built an amazing community and I'm glad to have been part of it.
I wish you luck in your future endeavors.
Though this isn't a goodbye, I hope to see you around every so often.
Bright nights forever.
Bright nights forever!
Bright nights forever, guys.
I hope you always remember the bright nights, everyone.
Even in 50 years, you will be like, wow, that's part of a cult called the bright nights.
You're like, was I in a cult?
I hope you... the cult of cousins.
Bright nights forever!
I hope you'll always remember the bright nights, even in like 50 years or so.
April, I've been with you since the old day.
I don't think this thing is that long, but I know it's long enough to know you mean a lot to me.
I'll miss you and your content.
Thank you for everything.
I won't forget a single moment.
Oh, I'm back.
Yes, I have a lot of you guys that have been with me since my Overwatch days.
Since 2017, isn't that crazy?
And it's like... it's just crazy for me to think that you guys put up with me for so long.
For the many hiatuses I've done for all of you too.
Like, I would be like... I wouldn't even let you guys know.
I just disappear for months and be like, hey guys.
And then I'll be like, welcome back now.
But this is the final... the final goodbye.
This will be the final goodbye.
So, this is not a hiatus.
I just need to reiterate that this is...
I know I've done a lot of hiatuses in my time.
But this is not... I have to... I really have to reiterate that this is not a hiatus.
So that's why I'm like... really surprised that so many of you stayed with me for... for so long.
Even with all the shit I did, I pulled on you guys.
Even with all this shit I pulled on you guys.
I don't even warn anyone.
I'm just like... I'm gone.
I'm just like... sorry.
I'm missing for 4 months.
I'm sorry.
I know I've only been here for a couple days.
But thank you for making me laugh so hard.
Your laughs are so contagious.
And I love it when you say...
It is.
I wish I'd discovered you sooner.
And I wish you all... Thank you, Sarah.
Thank you.
That... that really does mean a lot.
Dear Shun'o, here son.
This is my old body pillow.
It will laugh at you if you need it.
Hug... hug this anime girl when you're sad, boy.
Hahahaha.
Boy, are you sad?
Hug the pillow.
Hahahaha.
And you go up to the little boy.
Bar nights forever.
Hahahaha.
Alright, let's...
Bop bop bop.
Unfortunately, we're cousins.
Oh my god.
See me?
Unfortunately, I discovered your channel on the day you announced your graduation.
And during the last month, I wasn't able to join you because of college.
I would be tired and fall asleep.
But I've been able to watch some videos and it's been fun.
I just want to wish you good luck with the future and thank you for brightening up my day.
Aww, thank you whoever sent that message.
Thank you guys.
I just...
Thank you everyone.
Hahahaha.
It really does mean a lot.
Like, I'm just happy that even for some people, for those who are like the short times you guys watch me, that I still left an impression on all of you.
And that really does mean a lot.
It really does.
I'm gonna hide my doki-mokura and play streams and laugh from inside it.
Hahaha.
Man, I remember finding out like one of you and playing that perspective and just laughing about it.
It's sad to see you go, but it was fun while it lasted.
Oh my god.
What was it?
What was that game?
The game... the one that... where I broke the game?
And... and I...
What was that perspective game again?
I already forgot.
But... and then I ended up...
Apparently there was a... I ended up like brute forcing my way to solving the apple game.
Superliminal.
Yes, super...
Yeah, I forget every game I touch.
And then... and then you guys remember that apple part?
So you know, I remember how you like solve the apple part.
So apparently the way I solved it was not a very conventional way of solving it.
The tiny apple.
I was not supposed to solve it like that.
Hahahaha.
For some reason, the tiny apple just... I just made so many apples.
That one tiny apple managed to drift towards me.
And... and then I just slowly made more.
Hahahaha.
It was so tiny, but I did it.
Every puzzle I did...
For tiny apple...
Every puzzle I did in Superliminal was not a very conventional way of solving it.
I broke that game so many times.
Because I can... I broke it so many times.
Gumi!
Thank you for the raid, Gumi!
Thank you!
I hope you had a great stream.
I saw you were playing Pokemon Snap earlier, Gumi.
How was it?
But thank you again for the raid, guys.
Thank you again.
Thank you, Gumi.
I hope you had a great stream.
I'm just reading our Marshmallow stuff.
I don't... I don't...
Final... Final messages...
Oh, good luck in your Subathon!
Tomorrow, Gumi.
Good luck!
Oh, we have a great Sub...
I heard like a maximum extension is like 72 hours or something.
Like...
Hahaha.
Gumi, are you gonna...
Are you gonna sleep?
Like...
Hahaha.
Are you gonna do a sleep stream, Gumi?
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
So...
Hey, Berg.
Just last minute message to say thanks for all the laughs.
At first, I found you on Twitter and just followed for art.
But I got curious one time when I saw you streamed and were playing Apex and honestly just kinda was in awe watching you play so different from what I've done myself.
You inspired me to try more and I actually felt like I improved a lot.
From there, I just showed up because I was up way too late way too often.
And it was always a blast to be around and hear that laugh.
I know I stole my sword with the points but I honestly glad I got to help out even if it wasn't that much.
You helped...
I...
Is this Azer?
This has to be Azer.
You're the only one that stole the mod sword.
Hahaha.
Azer, I know this is you because you're the only one that stole the sword out of all of us.
But Azer, you helped out a lot.
I love you.
You helped out especially the Minecraft server.
You helped out so much in Minecraft as well.
We all stole the sword at one point but it was mods stealing swords from each other.
Hahaha.
I'm gonna miss hanging out with you and the rest of the...
The rest of the Bark Knights but I'm sure you're gonna keep doing amazing with what comes next.
And it was really awesome seeing how much effort and thought you kept putting into stream.
I think my favorite will always be seeing each year...
Each year.
I'm gonna cheer up simply by going live.
Well it's great to know we could help you out Blanky.
I gotta see you around.
I'm dying for my sword.
Hahaha.
Whenever she'll smile I get a brain...
But you guys do not know.
Um.
We had a point where I had a thing where people could steal mod from each other.
So like people who are not mods can steal swords from the mods.
And I thought it was like a fun thing.
But I realized I was like...
Okay this is gonna get really bad.
Cause what if like we had this secret lurker.
Like a secret lurker that was like...
Ha ha ha.
I'm gonna lurk in this channel just to steal mine.
And then he bans everyone.
Hahaha.
So I was like maybe this isn't a good idea.
So I had to get rid of that later.
I had to...
I was like you know what?
I realized there was a...
There might be a secret lurker there that wanted to save all the points just to ban everyone.
Hahaha.
Refresh them.
I'll...
Don't worry I'll refresh it guys.
I'll refresh it when we get to the bottom.
Hahaha.
How do you even do that?
It's just like they just redeem the points.
Um.
And they just slowly...
They just slowly just ban everyone in chat.
Hahaha.
Now he's upgrading his heist of them all.
I gave up my sword for Alex to feel strong man.
Hahaha.
Alright let's see.
Congrats on your graduation.
It's been wonderful to see your streams and hang out at the movie nights.
We'll surely miss you and your infectious laugh and continue to wish the best of you.
Don't be shy to still chat with us and we're all still here for you Doki.
Congrats again and take care.
Thief of the Bark Knight's heart.
Thank you dragon.
Thank you.
Ah guys I really do miss all of you.
Thank you everyone.
Hahaha.
I'm so happy.
It really does mean a lot.
It really does mean a lot that you guys are taking your time to write me these messages guys.
It really does.
Cause it takes me like 3 plus days to reply to anyone.
Hahaha.
It takes me that much.
You don't understand.
It drains my energy.
Typing a message to reply to someone in a message takes me like 3 plus days.
You guys might notice on twitter how I reply to people like 5 plus days later.
And I just reply to people in like a binge.
So like, you would see me reply to like 10 plus people all at once.
And they'll range from replies from yesterday to replies from messages from like 10 plus days ago.
And I'm like sorry.
Hahaha.
So it really means a lot.
It really does mean a lot that you guys are writing the words D.
I am, I truly am.
I can't believe I'm so mad by Cam.
Good luck, keep your head up.
Have a good one.
Congratulations.
We love you all!
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate you guys stopping by.
Really do.
Thank you for all for like hanging out this late.
I didn't think like the stream would go to this late already.
Thank you everyone.
But don't worry, we're almost to the... we're very close to the end.
We're very close to the end, guys.
Do not worry.
What are the things you wish you knew about VTubing and streaming before you started?
I'm debuting next month with no followers at all.
And I'm just really excited.
Just wanted to ask if you have any cardinal wisdom to best...
um... to best...
bestow.
I was like, best?
Overwatch?
Bestow.
I was like...
And also in the few years I hope you can look back this chapter of your life and smile.
I think it's really cool what you've done and what you've built.
You will go far, okay?
Can't wait for the last stream.
Oh my gosh.
For your advice, not gonna lie...
Okay, this is what I'm gonna tell you guys.
You might be like, what are you talking about?
But I will tell you this.
I will tell you this.
Do the opposite of everything I've done with my streaming career.
.
I know you guys are like, what do you mean?
But I'm serious.
I'm serious.
Do the opposite of everything I've ever done with my streaming career.
Because what I do is very unconventional and that's why my growth has been very, very slow.
Because I don't really... I guess it's like...
It is sad that I did get rejected for Twitch Partner like 40 times.
But it's like I did this to myself.
.
I did this to myself.
So what I'm saying is that first off, the biggest issue with my... with how I stream is that I don't... I never...
Before I announced my graduation, I've never like told anyone what time I'll be streaming, what day I'll be streaming and when I do stream...
When I do stream, it's like 2am.
.
It's like 2 in the morning.
And usually, if you want to grow as a streamer, do not stream at 2am.
.
Like there are a few degenerates out there like me that are awake at that time and also the people on the other side of the world.
But...
But it's not very good in terms of growth.
It's not very good when it comes to...
comes to growing as a streamer.
.
And definitely don't...
Definitely...
Definitely like...
network more.
Me, I just... I was in the void.
I was in the void and locked in my discord.
I deleted all the doors in my discord in my streaming room.
So I never really like interact much with other...
Especially in VTubing.
VTubing is all about networking and collaboration.
Not me though.
I was like, I look at VTubing and I'm just like...
I wanna be pretty.
.
I wanna have so many outfits.
And then I just wanna talk to my chat.
.
But...
It's...
It's true though.
Like...
Collaboration and networking is such...
So important in VTubing.
And I... That's all for so... That definitely affected my growth as a streamer.
Um... Cause I've been streaming on...
Well, last year I've been streaming consistently since 2020.
Um... Since the beginning of 2020 was like...
When I started consistently streaming.
And... Uh... I...
But I started streaming in 2017.
But it's just that I was so sporadic with my streams that...
Um... That like I would go...
Like I said, I would go on to this...
Uh... Really... Uh...
I'd go on to this...
Uh... Really like... Sporadic hiatuses and everything.
So that affected my growth and all.
I gotta stream consistently.
And... Yeah... Like those are my advice.
Stream consistently.
Uh... Do not stream at 2 in the morning.
.
Collaborate in networking.
I feel like at this day and age it's all about networking now.
Um... Like it when streamer reads their messages.
.
I love reading messages.
I always make sure to try and read all your messages guys.
I'm sorry if I ever missed any cause...
Cause like I... I... I don't know.
I was busy reading the Bee Movie script.
.
The Bee Movie script has...
Has made me very preoccupied as you guys know.
.
So I'm glad you guys uh...
Enjoyed your time in my community.
And with your cousins!
.
You get to my message in 2 to 3 days.
So thank you everyone for just being there with me.
And it really does mean a lot.
It really does guys.
.
So... Yeah just do the opposite of everything I've ever done.
As my streaming career.
You too can become a Twitch Partner.
.
And don't send them the Bee Movie script in your application.
Clearly I don't think they like the Bee Movie script very much in my Twitch Partner application guys.
.
Don't do that too.
Don't do that.
.
Even as a certain meeting it's been fun watching your stream for 2 months.
And times went fast.
It's kind of sad that you'll be graduating but it's your choice and we can stop you from doing what you want.
And finally good luck from your journey.
Thank you DG3.
Thank you everyone for the well wishes.
Thank you all.
If I wasn't graduating I would definitely write in my application World of Cousins!
.
But sadly I don't have a 5th attempt.
I don't have a 5th attempt on that.
.
How active are you gonna be after your last stream?
Are you just gonna disappear and you wanna see in other streams?
Who knows?
It's really hard to stream when you're on the run you know.
It's really hard to do anything when you're fucking running from the cops guys.
.
Have you ever tried motel internet?
Do the motels have internet guys?
I don't even know.
I'll find out later.
I'll find out Thank you for the 13 months at tier 1!
Thank you!
Can we get some bark nights real quick for Gilgamesh for the 13 months at tier 1.
Thank you, thank you!
I really do appreciate it guys.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you everyone!
The final bark nights.
Hello Doki!
Seeing as you seem to be leaving forever, I just want to thank you.
My sister passed away in November, but it didn't truly hit me until much more recently.
Among other things, your streams and videos kept me happy and distracted me from making any rash decisions.
To put it bluntly, you saved my life.
I decided to turn my life around on April 19th, and I felt so much better since then.
Why doubt I ever would have had the chance to do so?
If it hadn't been you.
Your personality, charm, and infectious laugh has been the highlight of the last 7 months I spent watching you.
And I can never thank you enough for truly reminding me that life is indeed worth living.
I will miss you forever and never stop loving you.
Awwww...
Hopefully that last part wasn't creepy.
No!
But... but... oh my god.
Ah, do you ever... do you ever...
Do you ever sense that I'm so happy that I was able to...
I was able to help you there.
I'm very happy to be there for you during your dark times.
I'm just happy to...
Uh...
I'm just happy...
I love you, have a good rest of your graduation.
Awwww thank you, I love you better!
Thank you!
I'm just happy that...
Uh...
I was able to help you there during your rough time.
And I was able to cheer you up during that time.
I just... like I said, I know I keep saying, but...
Every... I just... I just love making people...
Um...
Um... laugh.
And it's just... I'm just happy that I was able to do that.
I'm really happy to be able to do that for all of you.
And really... I... I just want you guys to feel better after that day.
And I think that's like...
People will be like, why do you laugh so much?
And I'll be like, what's wrong with you?
Like what?
You don't like to be happy?
Man, I'm sorry.
Like... like you're like...
What's wrong with laughing?
Is laughing your allergy?
Oh!
Hope you die in game!
From me laughing too much!
Like, I'm just happy that...
I was able to...
Uh... make you guys laugh.
And... I'm... I... it's really...
That's really all I wanted to do for you guys.
That's really it.
Like, I start my stream being...
Like, don't like me having to do Overwatch.
Someone did an uninstall Overwatch!
I see!
Hehehehe.
Alright.
Honestly...
Hey Doki.
Honestly, I didn't think I'd get emotional over this.
As I've been able to be very active for now and now.
Because of IRL stuff.
But wow, I'm literally tearing up writing this out.
I'm so happy to have had all these memories with you.
I still have the songs that I listened to because of your old playlist before Twitch DMCA.
I wish I could have edited for you more.
And I know about this.
I would hunt them 10 million thousand times.
Made...
This is an estimate.
I made more time to be able to make more memories with you.
I honestly will cherish this time of my life that we all got to spend together.
And I hope the same is for you, Sparrow.
Ah, you guys don't know who Sparrow is.
He's also been in the community for a very long time.
He's been there with us for very, very long.
And since the Overwatch game.
He's also the one that's edited a lot of our videos too.
On YouTube.
So...
I don't know if Sparrow is here right now.
Because he's been very busy lately with his school and work.
So...
It's really sweet that he managed to send a message in before the end.
And I'm going to miss him.
He has done so much for the community too.
He's also one of our mods.
He's also one of our mods too.
We'll miss your energy and that sweet laughter.
Thank you.
Whoever that was.
I'm going to miss your stream so much that you're such a positive ball of energy.
And I hope the future is kind to you.
Wherever it is that you're going to pursue.
May include making tomatoes extinct.
Don't get the last tomato.
Just wiped out tomato town.
Who's next?
Been a follower ever since your Overwatch days.
And I'm glad I stayed for the journey.
Chuki.
Thank you Chuki.
Thank you for everyone that stayed.
Since my Overwatch days.
It's really crazy because I went through so many different phases in my streaming career.
Like I went through different things I want to do.
Because I didn't know what I wanted to do.
I went through like Splatoon, Overwatch.
Remember when I used to be an artist?
I don't think we...
When was the last time I drew for you guys?
Because I was like, you know what?
I'm just going to talk to my chat.
I'm just going to talk to my stream.
Because I was like, I'm really just talking anyway.
I was really just talking anyways.
So I might as well just ditch the whole art part.
That's you.
You never drew during the art team.
I just wanted to be in the art category.
Alright.
And after this we refresh.
Hello there traveler.
How are you doing?
Hope you're doing well.
I'm mad at saying goodbye.
My brain does not function properly.
So I'm just going to blurt out some words then.
Where did it begin then?
I still remember I found out about your channel during quarantine.
The pure chaotic energy was a breath of fresh air.
It is true that I was not an active member of the community.
Not that I was active all the time.
But believe me, I loved all the stream I was able to see and enjoyed every second of it.
Loved your art.
Loved your PP.
But most importantly, loved you as a person.
It hurts to see you go.
But I respect your decision.
Whatever you do next, just know that we will always be there for you.
We will always support you until the next blue moon rises and night is bright.
Until the night is tight.
Goodbye.
If you decide to go on Heist again, do more PP.
Just know that we will be waiting here for you.
Let God cross your path once again.
Until then, goodbye for the last time.
Thank you for whoever wrote that.
Like I said guys, I will miss you guys so much.
And I'm glad I made such an impact on all of you.
Don't forget me.
If you closed your eyes, I will be there for you.
Thank you.
Yeah, there will be more.
There will be more guys.
Don't worry.
I'm just going to refresh this now.
But thank you whoever wrote this.
That was such a sweet message.
Thank you to whoever it was.
I see that we wrote some nice words as well.
Alright, let's scroll back up.
Oh my gosh, 10 more.
10 more.
Oh, you guys are so sweet everyone.
Thank you.
It's so sweet.
Eddie, thank you for the five bitties.
Thank you.
We prepared something special for your fans who will join me in the burstless and discord with...
Oh, okay.
Okay, I guess we're joining in the...
Oh, but I don't...
If you're sharing a video to me, I don't know if I can...
Can I share a video that's shared on the discord?
Is it possible to share that?
Oh, you guys are so sweet everyone.
I don't know.
I've never tried that before, guys.
I've never tried that.
Should be.
Okay.
Alright, alright, I'll do that then.
Hey Doki, I'm making this while you read the messages that everyone gave you and hear last.
It really makes me sad that I'll not hear it no more, but because it's different when it's in the moment.
Ah, words.
Just saying it was fun watching and hearing your loud, aggressive, and energetic voice.
I hope to see your twin in the infinite doors of opportunity.
Okay, you guys are so sweet!
What are you talking about?
What twin?
I'm an only child.
We never had... I never had a twin.
Not since 2014.
But thank you, thank you.
This stream is last minute.
I'm so sorry about that.
Though I did not speak a lot in chat, I would like to thank you for your time and effort you put into your stream.
I found you through a rain and I'm extremely happy that I stayed.
I want to thank you for all the laughter you brought to us.
I'll always remember the first movie night I hopped in to watch Souls with the community.
But nonetheless, I hope you have a happy graduation and I wish you the best on your new path of life.
I wish I'd learn about you sooner and talked more.
But as for now, I know you will be remembered and I hope you remember us too.
Of course I'll remember you guys!
Chat!
Of course!
Oh well, I'm so happy.
I'm so happy even the movie nights.
Even...
Like during movie nights, you guys all had an amazing time.
Because every time in movie nights, I try to be as involved as much as possible.
I even like paid to watch the movies legally for all of you.
Sometimes I would pay like 20 plus dollars to watch it legally.
Because it would be like, like Soul, I had to buy the ticket.
Or Raya.
But I am so happy that you guys all enjoyed.
All enjoyed the...
Riptrolls.
I bought, I even paid for trolls and that was the best decision of my life.
You wouldn't download a car!
That ad traumatized me!
But I'm glad you all enjoyed.
Especially movie night.
Movie night was so fun too.
Well movie night was so fun with all of you.
It was, it was.
I'll miss you guys!
Thank you, everyone.
And thank you for the other 8 bits.
Thank you so much.
Thank you Scooby too.
That's it.
Thank you so much, Ninja, for such a sweet message.
And thank you for all the stuff you've done.
Even though you've only been here for a short time, you really did leave an impact on all of us.
Especially the fun one.
The 1v1s we had and the 8 packs.
And the great big donation that you made for all of us, for food and Food Banks of Canada.
It really does mean a lot.
And the donation you did yesterday too.
Or two days ago.
Oh my gosh, thank you, Ninja.
It really was...
I'm so happy that you're all part of this community, guys.
Thank you for making this such an amazing community for me.
And an amazing community for all of you.
Hey Doki, it's your boy, Elsart.
Just wanted to say I miss you so very much.
Seeing that message for the final stream made me go in denial for a while until I made peace and want you to succeed.
I'm happy I found you on Recommended randomly at 2am.
Spending so much time even though I've missed most of the stream.
I have to watch the VODs when I can.
When today finally came, no lie, I cried home, mom.
And I got home from work.
I'll say that you made my nights amazing when I came by.
The smile you put on my face made my mouth hurt from smiling and trying not to laugh hard at 3 in the morning.
I'm gonna miss your streams.
Gonna miss hearing the jokes, the stories, chaotic energy, and of course your laughter.
Who knew that you could make me cry so hard for these 3 hours?
My mouth is being blistered when I wake up.
I wish you the best of luck.
And know that my eyes will be with you.
In your heart.
Love you.
Doki from all the many work nights.
Aw, thank you.
Thank you.
I'm sorry.
Thank you for such a sweet message.
Yeah.
I wonder how many people I...
How many people's parents or significant others or roommates I've woken up because of my laugh.
Especially when I stream at 3 in the morning.
I wonder how many of you guys accidentally woke up like whoever you're living with because of me.
Yes.
3 in time.
Time to get in trouble.
And we saw that.
That way I can go away bleeding that.
I switched my headphones up at 1 am.
I'm glad I have headphones on at all times.
It's a night terror.
I think you woke up my aunt.
I don't know what to put on my headphones.
I remember someone was like...
Someone was like...
Came to my chat and was like...
I heard my boyfriend laughing.
And I knew it was from your stream.
And I was like, whoops.
I was like...
And she was like, I was trying to sleep.
I don't remember who it was.
I wish I remember.
I thought it was so funny.
I was like, I'm so sorry for waking you up.
I'm so sorry.
She was like, I knew she was watching your stream.
Because you woke me up.
You woke my roommate in that massage stream.
It was like the funniest shit.
Moving talkie.
And I forgot to make my day riding.
Asking what was on.
Because I heard doki screeching.
I have open back headphones.
So I haven't been able to hear the crazy laugh from another room.
When I went up to do one thing or another.
And I have my doki's laugh.
I got yelled at by my parents for laughing too hard from your streams.
Yeah, I feel like everyone has gotten either like reprimanded or yelled at because of me.
I'm sorry.
But not really.
I mean, I got annoyed.
You can't believe it.
Everyone is living me as annoyed at your laugh.
They need to hear it the most.
Ah, yes.
What's it called?
Stockholm syndrome.
I'm just going to give whoever it is Stockholm syndrome.
Hi again.
One second marshmallow message before the end.
I'm really super happy that I got to fly on your stream.
Although I haven't been coming as often as I would like.
I'm always so happy to feel so welcomed by you.
Thank you for being so amazingly kind and funny to yourself.
One of your moments was when I said fuck you.
Oh dear.
I should have stopped laughing and just said it out loud.
I didn't know how hilarious and goofy you are.
I wish I didn't have to see you leave because I always wanted to be able to see you having fun with the bark knights.
I'm going to miss hearing your laugh and witty humor.
Please take care of yourself.
And even though you're going to be leaving this discord, please feel free to come back and hang out with all of us again.
We're seriously going to miss you so very much.
Thief of bark knight hearts.
Take care again.
You'll destroy something with your...
About that, I...
It did not work.
The next day was awful.
Today was not a very good day for me.
I.e.
today was not a very good day for me.
When I woke up.
Let's just say that.
Those noodles were very...
It was very rough.
Do not eat spicy noodles.
Do not eat noodles that are way spicier than you are used to.
That's for sure.
I just need more training.
Don't do that.
Don't... don't...
You remember when I said do the opposite of everything I do?
Do the opposite of everything I do.
This is one of the many examples.
Or you should do the opposite of everything I do, chat.
Doki, you are amazing.
I found your... you...
I found your Gumi showed me...
Uf...
You make me happy.
I've only known you since October.
And because of...
And because for me you were always early in the morning.
I miss them a lot.
But I sit here not crying.
I'm enjoying the amazing thing about you.
I don't know how amazing it is.
Your... your...
Your contagious just hearing makes me happy.
I just have sense with a clip of you laughing.
I know they could have said...
They could have said no.
I hope what happens in your life is amazing.
But please don't catch you.
You remember us and you get sad.
Think of us.
They need to... us.
Call upon us.
The bark nights will always rise for you.
Yesterday, today, tomorrow.
50 years from now.
Um...
Or 200...
2000.
I know saying all of you only means...
So much from a random person over... on the internet.
But please...
From as much as this word from a tomato.
It's true, genuine, and will never waver.
Which I got.
I'm crying and sad.
I would love if you could stay.
I know you can.
I hope you don't disappear off the...
Internet.
Emochi.
Awww...
Thank you, Emochi.
I'm..
Happy that...
You've been enjoying these streams.
And...
Remember...
You were here for the journey.
And...
You were here for me live.
And you get to hear the laugh live too!
Come on.
People will be like.
People will be like...
Oh!
Listen to this vibe.
Of her laughter?
That ain't the same.
But you had live laughter!
But I'm so happy you guys are there.
You guys are there for me.
For this journey.
Bark nights forever!
Bark nights forever.
Alright, just make sure that you're okay.
It's not health reasons.
It's just the... Do you want me to be in jail?
For robbing a bank, guys?
I'm pretty sure bank people are like...
You can't go... I mean, they are for the first time.
But when you rob them a second time, they're like, no, no, no!
No, no, no!
We're gonna fucking put you in jail!
And I'd rather be in Motel 6 than in jail.
Cause then I could order Uber Eats.
Well, then I... My bunnies can order Uber Eats.
I said most of my thoughts in another document.
But I couldn't pass up one more opportunity to say how much you mean to me.
And how happy I am for you.
I'm gonna miss all this so much.
Thanks again for modding me at another mod's expense that one time.
And letting me be a part of everything.
I love you so much.
I'll always support you and always be your number one sim and number one mod.
Love, CeeVee.
Oh my gosh.
CeeVee, thank you.
CeeVee was also one of the original mods and one of the original mods and one of the...
One of my first viewers when I streamed Overwatch.
And it's crazy.
He's been here for a long time.
He's been in this journey for a long time.
And it's crazy that he's been a sub to me for so long.
Too.
Like a tier 3 CeeVee.
And it really does mean a lot that you've been with us for such a long journey.
And for...
For...
For so many years.
And I always say...
I always say that I can never believe that.
Especially the people from months ago, like years ago that's been with me to this day.
To this day.
I recognize so many of you guys for over...
Over the years that you're new and old.
It's just crazy to think about every time.
Hello, hello.
Resident Mon and VR Chat Addict here.
As you probably have already seen.
Doki Maple Bird, I hereby thank you for all the amazing months of entertainment.
I'm so glad I was able to share the joy and laughter HeartContagious is for every stream.
Coming from the hair-bringer self-appointed leader of the Doki Squad.
And number one simp fan.
I assure you the money I spent on the gifted subs, merch, charity, and whatnot was never a waste.
As all of it pays for the last nine months of horrors, stream games, horror streams, puzzle games, the shooty, McFace, Apex streams, and just the chat streams with emo art in the background.
It has been some of the greatest content to ever grace my eyes and bring out laughter I never thought was possible.
And everything else you have also helped me by being my true self and be who I am.
Now push my career in the avenue you have paved.
Like a thief to my blood-heart.
You were just another Jane Doe.
You're the Doki that everybody should know.
Thank you Ruby!
And Arlo and Ruby!
Thank you for the five gifted subs each to the community!
Can we get some more barf nights real quick for Arlo and Ruby.
For Arlo and Ruby.
Thank you so much.
For the ten gifted subs.
Thank you for the subs and all.
Thank you everyone.
Oh gosh, Ruby.
Thank you so much, Ruby.
Especially when you like, sometimes you might be the only mod in chat too during my really fucked up hours.
And it really means a lot.
Yamashii, thank you for the five gifted too!
Alright, more Park Nights.
But as I was saying, thank you.
Can you guys do more Park Nights again?
In chat.
But I was saying, thank you for just sticking around in the chat and just helping out with the modding.
And moderating and stuff when everyone's asleep.
It really does mean a lot when you're like, busy at work.
It does mean a lot, Ruby.
Cause I know like, some of my hours are really fucked up.
So thank you again.
Thank you for all your time and all your energy spent on the stream.
And for how generous y'all are.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Okay, I'm gonna refresh one more time.
And then if that's it, I will...
Oh!
There's one more!
I'm so happy I met you in one of your art streams.
2020 was a harsh year for all of us.
And it was probably the worst year for me.
But after joining your stream for the first time, you really made my days a lot better.
I'm gonna miss that contagious laugh, your jokes, and just you in general.
You've been such a joy.
And every time I come in, even if I'm lurking, I always feel comforted in being in your streams.
Thank you for letting me be a Park Night.
And sharing so many fun moments.
And sharing so many fun, amazing memories with us.
Thank you.
Thank you, Ambrose.
It really does.
Like I said, I know I keep saying this a lot, but I'm just happy that I was able to make your days better.
Especially during the quarantine months.
Like, it's rough when you're not able to go outside sometimes.
So I'm happy that I was able to give you, like, smiles and entertainments.
Make you forget about the bad things out there in the world.
And it just means a lot.
It really does.
Thank you again.
Thank you, everyone.
It really does.
And Rancid, thank you for the 300 bits.
And for the Tier 1 community sub gift.
And Ocelot for the gift too.
Thank you, everyone.
More Park Nights in chat.
More Park Nights in chat, guys.
Thank you.
Thank you, everyone, for all the gifts.
Guys, it really does mean a lot.
Thank you.
It really does.
Thank you, everyone.
You guys made me tear up so many times.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, all.
Thank you.
Alright.
Before the last thing, we have a little special thing from Roar.
So let me join the Discord real quick and see if I can do the thingy.
So just...
See if I can set it up properly for you all.
I don't know how to do it properly.
So...
I'm trying to figure this out, guys.
I'm dumb.
I don't know if you guys remember that part about me.
Alright.
Yes, my Twitter handle will be the same.
It will be the same, guys.
Do not worry.
Let me see if I can do this.
Let's see.
I don't think I...
Can I?
What's it called?
Oops.
What's next?
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
I need to try to figure out which...
Guys, I'm trying to figure this out, guys.
There we go.
We're in.
Alright, Roar.
Let's do it.
Let's go.
We're in.
Oh.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait.
Before...
Wait, wait, wait.
Don't do it.
Don't.
I just realized.
I fucked up.
We are not in.
We are...
I fucked up.
This is...
Look how tiny this box is.
Okay.
This is pretty scuffed, but I'm figuring this out as we go along, guys.
As we go along.
Is this it?
We're in.
Ninja with the 45!
Thank you, Ninja.
Can we get some...
Before we play this video, can we get some...
Barth Knights real quick to Ninja.
Thank you.
I really do love you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, Ninja.
For the 45.
Give the songs.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Oh my gosh.
It is lagging roar.
You might have a little problem.
I see your mouth.
It's a very long video, just so you know.
How long is it?
Oh, wait.
Is it...
How long is it?
Oh, you mean the video itself?
I don't know how to fix shit.
Oh, shit.
Okay, wait.
Is it fixed?
All right.
Over and out.
It's an hour!
I can't stream this for an hour.
I'm sorry.
Is there a way to stream like a quickie of it?
I will watch it after if I can.
Oh, shit.
I can't do an hour.
I'm sorry.
I'm...
Oh, or is there a way to do like...
A little...
Well, that's where I should have...
No, it's just that, I have like something else planned for you guys.
And I can't...
I don't wanna, I don't wanna like...
Delay this for way too long.
But...
I can upload the video to YouTube.
I can upload the video.
I'll upload a video to YouTube too.
Can we get one more daily song at the end?
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
I'll upload a video on YouTube and we...
I'll do a premiere!
And then we can all watch it together at the end of the stream.
How about that?
I'll do a premiere tomorrow!
We'll do a premiere of Rory's video on YouTube tomorrow.
And we can all watch it on stream.
Yeah, that'll be so much more fun!
I think that'll be much more fun.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, let's do that.
Is that okay with you, Rory?
So we'll all be there too.
Watching it live, all of us together.
Yeah, no, no, tomorrow on a YouTube premiere.
It'll be on my YouTube channel as a premiere.
Is that okay?
Rory?
Or would you prefer if we watch it now?
Would you prefer it today?
Well, you pick, because...
I'm gonna watch this video.
And it'll give you...
You can add more stuff.
I'll upload it for everyone to see.
Yeah, and everyone can see it too.
It won't just be me.
Yeah, so follow...
Oh my god, Rory, go to...
Rory!
I'm so sorry, Rory!
Oh my god, I hope you're okay.
Rory!
Are you okay?
Okay, don't worry, don't worry.
We're almost at the stretch.
And then you can pass out, and then we'll have a YouTube premiere.
Um...
And we'll have a YouTube premiere.
We'll watch it together.
As the Bark Knights.
The final thing.
The final thing, as Bark Knights together.
Final thing, Rory.
You wanna sneak peek?
Oh, let's do a sneak peek!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Sneak peek, sneak peek!
Okay, okay, let me...
We'll do a sneak peek, and then the rest will be a YouTube premiere.
And then we'll have the rest as a YouTube premiere.
That's good, that's a good idea.
Yeah.
Okay, let me fix this real quick.
I need a...
Sorry guys, I just need to fix this.
I just need to reset, and then...
Oop.
Okay.
Alright, play it!
We'll get a sneak peek, and then...
Um...
You need a trailer?
Oh, just show the beginning.
We'll do a sneak teaser.
Five minute teaser.
Five to ten minute.
And then...
We'll all watch the rest tomorrow on the YouTube premiere.
Alright, let's go.
Alright,
let's go.
Thank you, Rory.
Thank you for spending so much time for all of us.
It really does.
It's a whole thing?
Thank you.
Thank you, we really do appreciate it, Rory.
Thank you for spending that much time for all of us.
It really does mean a lot.
Woah!
A documentary!
April 16, 2021.
I'm picking the one song that I want to sing.
Guys, this was very hard.
Because I wanted it to be a good song.
That was...
What I wanted to share with you guys for the announcements.
So, it was very hard picking this song.
And I feel like I'm not going to do very well on this song.
Because there's like this very high note.
One for a specific line.
And I might just sing it lower.
That's me.
Who's the real one?
That's okay.
We'll have our last conversation.
And drink our last cup of coffee.
Someday...
We might be 80.
Let's do it.
And think about the different things we used to say.
All the memories of you Will just become a ghost of a smile.
Caught in the wind.
Someday...
It'll be the last day.
This is the last day!
I'll be graduating on May 14.
It must be a surprise for all of you.
We're not crying!
I honestly had no idea how I was going to transition.
Today we celebrate.
It's final time.
The finale is about to be announced.
Relax.
Enjoy.
Let's go out with a bang.
Shall we?
It was but a simple rain.
It was a more innocent time.
Just got into watching P-Super's True Horror Live.
And was perusing the Twitch scene.
Then...
Somewhere there was what she made of you.
First I was in denial.
Her laugh was in denial.
Surely that must be her whole schtick.
But after a few moments...
The topic of Funko Pops arose.
My stone cold heart hadn't laughed so hard in so long.
I had forgotten.
I was so scared.
I had forgotten what it felt like.
I was still innocent.
I didn't realize.
This was just the beginning.
The more I watched, the more I became aware of the fact.
That I was indeed witnessing P-Consent.
P-Consent!
P -Consent!
I've seen that with my eyes.
And just chatting.
And of course, Fun Apex times with Acid and Wabic.
And the personalities and skill of the shooty game.
Made for some great fun.
And the moments and hilarious times.
I needed here.
Placid!
I actually blocked you.
Okay, we know this is everyone's fault.
This is everyone's fault.
It's not my fault.
You get 70 damage.
What the fuck was I supposed to do?
Define.
That's what you were supposed to do.
I was like, okay, I'll just take your portal.
Wait, it's in the middle of the fucking open.
You already died two times before that.
It's always Acid's fault.
It's never my fault.
It's never the streamer's fault.
I'm streaming.
Kiss, kiss, kiss.
He was like, oopsie.
Alright, alright.
I'm waiting for you guys to...
You know like, Acid and Wabic arguing just sound like an old married couple.
When they argue.
It's a cousin's fault.
I'm joining streams.
Put a big ol' grin on my face.
I started to notice a flaw.
A chink in the content armor.
A chink in the content armor?
You're a terrible freak.
I've taken you to someone's home.
You've always seemed absurd to me.
Since I know you give more than you grow.
The thought of you worshiping money over anything else.
How dare you!
You can't even ask back into the community.
The thought of you...
No!
I've been exposed!
It's not only just Uber Eats.
I feel attacked.
The smile on your face and the laugh so bright it would momentarily...
Look at the mouse traveling.
...
I hope that in some form...
Give me a second.
Oh no!
More nights for Kurama...
Kurama Roy!
Thank you, Roy, though.
It's really...
Is that the...
We wanna end this with a sneak peek?
We might...
This might be the sneak peek!
That was a really good teaser, though.
Roy.
That was...
This is so good!
Oh, we keep...
Let's go.
Let's keep going.
Oh, wait.
Are we going... Keep going?
First...
This is so good.
...
I'll do a premiere of the video.
And just join the YouTube.
Just subscribe to the YouTube channel.
And I'll make a little premiere for the video for tomorrow.
And then...
That was beautiful.
That was really beautiful.
Thank you for all your time.
Even though it was a sneak peak, I can tell how much work...
Roy, you should put your own message there before you give me the video.
Put your own message there.
You really deserve it.
Really, in the deep of my heart, thank you for making that video, Roy.
It really is beautiful.
That little sneak peak you showed us was truly beautiful.
And I'm gonna upload a... I'm gonna make a little...
I'm gonna make a little schedule for a premiere of it tomorrow.
And then the person I appoint for the Discord owner...
will make a notification for you of what time it will be.
So, END!
Thank you for gifting 29 subs to the community!
Thank you!
Can we get some bright nights real quick for Ed?
Thank you, thank you, thank you everyone.
Again, like I said, it really does mean a lot.
All the love and support you've shown me.
And we're finally on the final stretch.
We're finally at the final stretch of the stream.
And I'm gonna do a little V-Rite back for a bit to set up for the final thing that I wanna do for you guys.
And then...
And then we'll see you from here.
Thank you again everyone.
Can we get some bright nights for Ed for the 25 gifted subs?
Thank you again.
Alright guys, I'm gonna be right back.
And...
Um...
And then...
Yeah!
I'll be back!
Oh my gosh.
We're finally here.
The last stretch.
I just wanna...
I guess my final message is to all of you.
Like...
I honestly...
I...
Like I said...
I never thought I would...
Build a community like this ever.
I...
I never thought that so many of you...
I didn't even think that so many of you would come to the final stream.
It really...
I'll be like...
I hope I have at least a hundred of you guys show up for the final stream.
Cause I want you guys all to be here.
To like watch this live.
And like...
And just be here.
And just experience the last stream.
The last moments we have together.
And...
And it really means a lot.
Thank you all of you guys for...
For come...
For sticking around.
And...
And just...
Hang out with me.
And...
Whoa!
What's that?
What's going on?
What?
Oh no!
Oh they're here!
Oh!
They are still here!
Oh shit!
We made it too long!
We made it too...
Okay.
Okay guys.
We...
Okay we might have...
We might have...
Don't ever catch me!
Okay we might have.
We might have fucking...
Drag this stream on too long.
Okay.
Okay guys.
I need to...
Okay I need to...
Give me a sec guys.
I need to...
I need to change real quick everyone.
I need to take off my...
Skinsuit!
They can't catch me if I'm a tomato!
Tomato!
You can't catch me!
I'm a tomato everyone!
Do not worry!
I'm taking off the skin suit!
There you go!
It's okay!
We're fine!
We're tomato!
They don't know who I am!
You don't know who I am!
Oh gosh!
Okay, okay, okay chat.
Remember when I said I had to take a day off to teach the bunnies how to drive?
Yeah, this is what the lessons are for!
Bow-Bow!
May-May!
Get the car running!
We're going on the run now!
I can't believe I had to dispose of that skin suit!
I have to make a new identity!
Maybe... maybe a new hairstyle.
What clip on hair should I choose next guys?
Do you think I can pull a non-blonde look?
I don't know.
But I can't let the cops find me that easily though.
So I gotta dig around my tree of fast-for-treats so they can do.
Gosh, it's so much work to do.
Bye!
You think you see me on the streets?
No snitching, alright?
We're in this together now!
Park nights forever!
But before I go on my park nights, here's your little secret.
I robbed that bank again for a reason!
This special gift for all you after I go wasn't cheap.
But it was worth it.
Now here's one last kiss for all of you.
Here's one last kiss.
One last...
Wha!
Wait!
W-what?
I  Jessica
I  Jessica I  Jessica
Meet again, my dear bark knights.